Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Linus. Guten Morgen Tim.
Hundertste Sendung. Wollen wir mal was ganz besonderes machen?
Ich würde sagen, ja, wir können ja mal das Hand freigeben.
Netzpolitik, die einhundertste Ausgabe Talinus. Zwei Jahre haben wir jetzt hier abgeritten und jetzt auf einmal das.
Ja, wir wir haben die hundert erreicht. Wir sind dreistellig. Wir gehören jetzt zum Establishment.
Und äh man muss sich natürlich überlegen, äh wie man wie man so etwas gebührend feiert.
Wir haben uns überlegt, wir wir hätten uns beschenken können, gegenseitig. Wir hätten.
Beschenken können und dann haben wir uns überlegt, dann beschenken wir lieber die Hörer und zwar mit einer Perspektive, die hoffentlich das, was wir mit unseren.
Mit unseren wöchentlichen Meldungen von uns geben, einfach mal um eine gewisse Metaebene erweitert.
Und da gab's eigentlich nur einen, das ist Hans-Christian Ströbele.
Genau
eigentlich den meisten durchaus ein Begriff sein für die Leute die bei dem Namen kein explizites Echo verspüren er ist schon seit
äh langer, langer Zeit Teil des politischen Geschehens in äh Deutschland. Ist in den siebziger Jahren so als raff äh Anwalt äh einer größeren Öffentlichkeit,
bekannt geworden und hat so ein bisschen als äh des der deutschen Politik eigentlich bis heute äh immer wieder alles in Schwingungen gehalten bis zuletzt, wo er jetzt äh nach Russland gefahren ist und äh Edward Snowden besucht hat.
Hat er noch die Grüne Partei gegründet und die und die TAZ.
Ja, also hat auf jeden Fall äh einen ordentlichen Fuß ab,
äh hinterlassen und es auch äh nach wie vor dabei, äh neue zu generieren. Wir sind dann einfach mal in den Bundestag marschiert und haben ein längeres Gespräch geführt und ohne jetzt viel drum rum zu reden
wo man dann einfach mal darauf überleiten.
Wir befinden uns äh im Bundestag, zumindest in dem Teil, wo die Bundestagsbüros sind und zu hundertsten Sendungen von Logbuch Netzpolitik begrüßen wir Hans-Christian Ströbele. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag und willkommen hier in dem alten Gebäude von Schalkolowski, glaube ich, äh von der her, von dem er aus äh irgendwie sein Wirtschaftsimperium dirigiert hat, damals, seine Westkontakte und so.
Aber das ist jetzt umgebaut und alles ganz sauber hoffentlich auch in den Wänden.
Garantiert abhörfrei. Ja, warum sind wir hier? Ähm.
Sind ja nun äh man kann, glaube ich, sagen, alter Hase, was das Politische äh Geschäft betrifft und äh haben da schon so einiges gesehen und gehört,
Und wir wollten heute mal ähm ein wenig in ihre Erfahrung eintauchen, auch um einfach ein paar Zusammenhänge zu verstehen, die uns äh bei unserer wöchentlichen Berichterstattung ähm immer wieder,
vor die Flinte laufen.
Uns dem zu nähern, würde ich gerne mal so ein bisschen bei ihnen am Anfang.
Anfangen. Als sie äh sich entschlossen haben, Rechtsanwalt zu werden.
War das schon so ein bisschen der Gedanke dabei, sich um diesen Start zu kümmern? War das schon so eine Entscheidung für das Staatsgefüge.
Nee, das war gegen das Staatsgefüge. Äh ich war habe damals äh die Meinung gehabt, äh die Überzeugung gehabt.
Das war neunzehnhundertsiebenundsechzig. Äh das wird dringend eine Revolution in Deutschland und in der westlichen Welt brauchen. War ja nicht nur ich, sondern viele andere in.
Ländern Europas und den USA Lateinamerikas.
Und ich hab mich damals als Referenda schon engagiert,
äh um Studenten, äh die vom Staat verfolgt wurden, sei es mit Strafverfahren, sei es mit Relegationsverfahren oder anderem Ärger, mit dem Staat zu vertreten, zu verteidigen, ihnen zu helfen,
Äh und.
Ich wollte dann Rechtsanwalt werden und Rechtsanwalt bin ich dann auch geworden und hab dann diese Tätigkeit immer weiter betrieben. Einmal natürlich als Beruf äh,
Ich habe auch ganz normale, ganz normalen Strafverfahren überwiegend oder Familiensachen vertreten. Aber eben auch immer.
Seit neunzehnhundertsiebenundsechzig, mit einem politischen Antrieb, politischen Impetus, das heißt immer auf Seiten,
die schwächer waren
derer, die verfolgt wurden, gerade vom Staat verfolgt worden. Das eine habe ich gemacht dann, um meinen Lebensunterhalt zu verdienen, für mich und das Büro. Das hieß ja damals sozialistisches Anwaltskollektiv.
In Westberlin und das andere habe ich gemacht aus politischen Gründen, weil ich die revolutionäre Umwälzung in Deutschland in der Welt wollte und die, die das auch wollten, unterstützt habe,
wir haben uns damals als Genossen und Genossinnen bezeichnet in Westberlin.
Hat nichts zu tun äh mit dem real existierenden Sozialismus auf der anderen Seite der Mauer und äh.
Danach hat sich das immer wieder äh bei den,
verschiedenen sozialen Bewegungen der nächsten Jahrzehnte angekoppelt, also hier in Berlin kennt man natürlich die Hausbesetzerbewegung der achtziger Jahre oder die ein,
vorher schon die Friedensbewegung, die Anti-AKW-Bewegung äh da war ich überall engagiert, ich war äh vor den Atomkraftwerken in Brockdorf, von Wackersdorf und habe immer mit
demonstriert, aber auch äh mich als Rechtsanwalt äh betätigt, zur Verfügung gestellt, manchmal auch um zu vermitteln und so und das ging dann.
Heute Ende der.
Siebziger Jahre hab ich dann mitgeholfen hier in Berlin die Alternative Liste für Demokratie und Umweltschutz das war so 'ne Vorläufe der Grünen,
zu gründen. Das waren Zusammenschluss verschiedenster unterschiedlicher Gruppierungen äh damals in Westberlin. Öko-Bewegung, ähm
Anti-AKW-Bewegung, Friedensbewegung, Frauenbewegungen, die sich da zusammengetan haben und viele linke Gruppen muss man ja auch immer wieder sagen, äh um äh dann die Welt
auch zu verändern, nicht mehr ganz so mit der Revolution, aber äh.
Die war ja dann immerhin schon Teil der Regierung, zumindest hier in Berlin.
Dann noch nicht. Nein, das kam erst viel spät,
Ende der siebziger Jahren haben wir die gegründet, alternative Liste und die hat dann existiert tatsächlich bis zum äh
Bis zum Fall der Mauer faktisch. Wir waren dann relativ bald der Landesverband äh der Grünen. Die Grünen wohnen im Bundesgebiet überall gegründet, auch andere Alternativeisten. Man hat sich dann zusammengetan und wir haben so.
Ungiert als Landesverband der Grünen und haben in der Tat zehn Jahre später, neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig äh nach einem entsprechenden Wahlergebnis, äh die erste rot-grüne Koalition hier in Berlin gegründet.
Mit Walter Momper als Bürgermeister, auf den wir damals große Hoffnung gesetzt haben, die enttäuscht wurden.
Und äh ja, ich habe sogar damals äh davon geschwärmt, das sei die Jahrhundert-Chance,
habe ich das ausgedrückt, als ich das äh unseren Mitgliedern versucht habe, klarzumachen, dass man so eine Koalition machen soll und das ist leider nicht eingetreten im Jahr neunzehnhundertneunundachtzig,
Zu Beginn des Jahres ist diese Koalition äh zustande gekommen, glaube ich, im März oder so. Und äh,
Ende des Jahres war ja dann schon ganz was anderes wichtig, nämlich die Demonstration im ganzen Ostblock vor allen Dingen auch in Ostberlin.
Jetzt haben sie gesagt, Revolutionen stand äh auf der Agenda.
Gegen was musst du denn da revoltiert äh werden? Ich meine, Deutschland hatte ja nun siebenundsechzig schon seine Umwälzungen äh gerade hinter sich äh gebracht, seine ersten nach dem Krieg. Was äh.
Was was war an der Stelle der der Gegner, was gegen was muss die hier revolutioniert werden.
Das waren kapitalistische Verhältnisse, Ausbeutung,
in Deutschland, in Europa, vor allen Dingen aber auch der dritten Welt. Wir haben uns immer als Internationalisten begriffen. An der Seite der Befreiungsbewegung, die damals äh sehr, sehr stark waren, etwa in Lateinamerika, aber auch in Afrika.
Haben wir uns weltweit gesehen und in Deutschland wollten wir die verkrusteten, gesellschaftlichen Verhältnisse aufbrechen, das heißt das ging von den
Wohngewohnheiten, also damals wurden die Wohnkollektive, damals hieß das erst Kommune und dann, dass man einfach mit mehreren jungen Leuten zusammen wohnen kann, auch ohne verheiratet zu sein und gleich eine Familie zu gründen und auch in größeren Verbänden
Das wurde hier ja gerade in Westberlin möglich gemacht, weil's große Wohnungen gab, aber es war auch eine sexuelle Revolution. Es äh wurde der verkrustete Paragraph hundertfünfundsiebzig, nachdem damals noch Männer, die mit Männern ins Be.
Gegangen sind, strafrechtlich verfolgt worden, zu meiner Anfangszeit, als ich Anwalt war
das waren vor allen Dingen der Antifaschismus, die Aufarbeitung der deutschen Vergangenheit
Wir fanden überall an den Hochschulen, am Gericht, wo ich war
waren überall ehemalige Nazis tätig. Im Bundesgerichtshof waren noch Anfang der sechziger Jahre die Richter aus der Zeit der Nazizeit äh waren auch am Bundesgerichtshof, also überall, wo wir hingucken
ein Lehrer an der Heidelberger Universität Herr Forsdorf war der, der den äh nationalen äh nationalsozialistischen Staat mit dem Führerprinzip gerechtfertigt hat. Das wusste
Es fiel uns äh wie Klappen von den Augen. Wir äh sahen das plötzlich, dass da unendlich viel aufzuarbeiten waren. Die Hochschulen waren äh zu revolutionieren. Wir haben da eine dritte Parität eingeführt und und und.
Äh wir waren davon überzeugt, das ist jetzt wirklich kein Witz, äh das geht nur mit einer revolutionären Veränderung.
Wie blicken sie denn da heute drauf? Weil sie sagen, sie waren überzeugt?
Na, es hat sich viel geändert. Also wir haben nicht das erreicht, sage ich ähm mal wieder, was wir wollten. Die politische Revolution, also,
Eine weitere Republik äh ganz anders strukturiert mit äh äh wo die äh Bankeninteresse, die Wirtschaftsinteressen nicht vorne dranstehen, äh sondern äh wirklich die Interessen der Bevölkerung,
Das haben wir so nicht erreicht. Aber wir haben in den äh gesellschaftlichen Verhältnissen in den Lebensgewohnheiten der Menschen unendlich viel
verändert. Also wenn ich manchmal so erzähle, wie ich als Student nach Berlin kam und dann selbstverständlich bei einer Wirtin wohnen musste und das Zimmer, das ich hatte, hatte so ein Glasfenster, wo die Wirtin dann ab.
Achtzehn Uhr immer reingucken konnte, ob ich da noch alleine bin und Frauenbesuch oder Mädchenbesuch war sowieso nicht, angesagt, das war verboten so. Also was man sich heute gar nicht vorstellen kann,
ähm das äh ist in heute äh fast allgemein gut. Es gibt immer noch Nischen, die
dieser alten Ordnung, aber ist eigentlich allgemein gut geworden, äh bis hin zur Ökologiebewegung, das wir entdeckt haben, was die Umwelt wert ist, äh was man da ändern muss und alles, was im Laufe der Jahre dazukam.
Die Entwicklung da aus dieser achtundsechziger Zeit heraus ähm
Die haben da ja sehr schnell Thermik äh entwickelt so und binnen von zehn Jahren sah man sich mit so einer Situation konfrontiert, wo äh die RAF äh begann mit ihren äh Aktionen.
Wie ist es denn dazu gekommen, dass sie dann da äh als Anwalt für die beklagten Terroristen agierten? Wie kam's dazu?
Ich äh war mit den meisten, gerade äh derer, die aus Berlin kamen, der ersten Generation, also,
Andreas Barder, äh Ulrike Meinhoff, Jan Karl Rasp, bei Holger, Mainz und so weiter. Vorher
zusammen gemeinsam auf der Straße. Wir haben gemeinsam gegen den Vietnamkrieg äh demonstriert. Das war übrigens auch eines
einer der ganz zentralen Anlässe für unseren Aufstand. Wir haben gesagt äh eine Gesellschaftsordnung, ein Bündnis, ein NATO-Bündnis
oder Verbündete, die ein Völkermord in Vietnam betrieben, die haben da Millionen von Menschen in die Steinzeit zurückgebombt und umgebracht, das muss man sich immer vor Augen führen, das hat uns jeden Abend vor dem Fernseher nicht mehr sitzen lassen,
und wir haben gemeinsam demonstriert gegen die Verhältnisse, gegen den Vietnamkrieg und dann sind einige äh zu neunzehnhundert äh neunundsechzig, neunzehnhundertsiebzig in Untergrund gegangen. Das waren ja nicht nur die Leute aus der RAF
und da war es fast selbstverständlich, dass wenn die im Gefängnis waren, einen Anwalt suchten, dass die mir eine Karte schicken und ich dann dahin gegangen bin oder gleich dahin gegangen bin, gesagt, ich vertrete die.
Verteidige die. Ich habe von der ersten Generation äh von allen Mandat gehabt, die dann verteidigt und einige Jahre meines Lebens damit gebracht, verbracht.
Verbracht, äh den äh eine faire Verteidigung zu besorgen, was mir leider, wie ich heute sage, nicht gelungen ist.
Wie ist das.
Wie es in dieser Situation, sie wussten, sie wussten in dieser Situation nicht, wie sich ihre Laufbahn noch weiterentwickeln wurde. Der Druck, der da auf einem relativ jungen Anwalt lastet, der sich mit mit so einem großen
Thema anlegt, der der diese, also welche Last.
Kam da irgendwie auch, also sage ich mal, von der öffentlichen Aufmerksamkeit. Sie werden ja heute noch ähm auf diese Verteidigerrolle von irgendwelchen ähm,
anderen Parteien äh reduziert, äh zurückgedrängt, äh dafür immer noch nach wie vor kritisiert. Ähm wie war der Druck damals auf sie?
Der Bauung her. Also erstens äh war für uns sichtbar.
Der Geheimdienst uns immer gegenwärtig. Man konnte morgens bei uns vom Balkon unseres Büros runtergucken und dann standen die da schon.
Und dann haben wir uns manchmal auch äh einen Witz draus gemacht. Da ist einer runtergegangen ist und um die Ecke gefahren ist und die dann hinterher und dann kam da kam sie wieder
wir hatten, wie wir später allerdings erst erfahren hatten, bei uns im Anwaltsbüro, eine Sekretärin, die gleichzeitig
Mitarbeiter, beamtete Mitarbeiterinnen beim Verfassungsschutz gewesen ist. Wir waren voll unter Kontrolle und wir waren äh.
Fast stellvertretend muss man sagen für die Mandanten, auch im Fokus der öffentlichen Diffamierung äh der Verfolgung und ich selber hatte ja auch ein Strafverfahren, bin selber auch verurteilt worden
Unterstützung einer kriminellen Vereinigung damals
weil äh das Gericht der Meinung war, ich sah in meiner Verteidigertätigkeit zu weit gegangen, also über die Grenzen, die einen Anwalt einhalten muss, hinaus äh,
gegangen. Und äh das war äh wir waren,
naja, die Ausgeschlossenen, die verpönten, der Terroristenanwalt und sowas äh in der Gesellschaft, ne? Das kann, das war, war,
eine ganz, ganz schwierige Zeit. Ich sage, immer wieder, auch heute mache ich ja manchmal äh große Belastungen mit, aber das ist überhaupt nicht vergleichbar zu dem, was ich da Anfang der siebziger Jahre erlebt habe. Auch persönlich.
Doch sind sie dann den den Schritt gegangen und eigentlich in relativ bald darauf ja sich.
In dem System selber äh zu engagieren, da für Veränderungen zu sorgen. Und sie haben gerade ähm schon sehr anfänglich von einer großen enttäuschten Hoffnung gesprochen.
Ja, ähm das bezog sich jetzt ganz konkret auf diese Koalition, die wir damals gegründet haben.
Glaube aber, dass das nicht die einzige enttäuschte Hoffnung ihrer Laufbahn war.
Nein, ich war auch immer der Meinung, ähm anders als die Linken jetzt in den Grünen und in der alternativen Liste
dass man, wenn es die Möglichkeit gibt, auch in Regierung gehen soll, weil man da einfach mehr bewegen kann
Wir erleben das ja jetzt gerade wieder, wenn man nur so davor sitzt und kritisieren kann und Anträge stellt, die sowieso abgelehnt werden.
Ist das relativ frustrierend, wenn man in der Regierung ist, hat man wenigstens die Chance, wenig sagen, da kann man viel erreichen, aber hat man die Chance, das eine oder andere zu bewegen, deshalb war ich da immer dafür und als ich da neunzig
neunundachtzig diese Möglichkeit gab, war ich deshalb auch heftig dafür, die zu ergreifen, aber,
Aus vielerlei Gründen, das hatte persönliche Gründe, war im regierenden Bürgermeister, hatte politische Gründe, Veränderungen der
Weltgeschichte Geschichte in Deutschland und hier in Berlin, äh dass das dann alles äh nicht geklappt hat. Ähm,
Natürlich waren immer große Frustrationen da drin und als wir dann und dann gleich einen Schritt weiterzumachen, neunzehnhundert äh.
Achtundneunzig, also ungefähr zehn Jahre später ähm die äh.
Rot-grüne Koalition auf Bundesebene.
Gegründet haben, war ich ja dann im Bundestag, da war ich zum ersten Mal wieder, ich war in den achtziger Jahren schon zwei Jahre mal im Bundestag und da war ich dann äh wieder im Bundestag und war da mit dabei,
und das war eine ganz, ganz schwierige Zeit. Äh wir.
Waren damals noch nicht richtig zusammen. Die Koalition gab's noch nicht, der neue Bundestag hatte sich noch nicht konstituiert. Da hat noch der alte Bundestag nach der Wahl beschlossen
sich äh an den Kriegsdrohungen
in Richtung Serbien zu beteiligen und dann nachher an ihrem Kosovo Krieg zu beteiligen. Wo ich plötzlich.
Mein Weltbild äh zusammenbrechen sah.
Ja. Ich würde ganz gerne nochmal äh zurückgehen zu den äh Raffprozessen, weil ich das einfach auch insofern sehr interessant finde, äh das erste Mal konfrontiert zu sein.
Mit dem Staatsgefüge und wie wir ja auch schon gehört haben, auch mit den Geheimdiensten.
Aber in einem eigentlich, ja, rechtsstaatlich definierten Prozess.
Eben nicht. Das war ja das Schlimme. Damals.
Definiert. Also ich sage, äh es hätte.
Von staatlich.
Es hätte einer ja, also man müsste ja, man würde ja davon ausgehen, dass das sozusagen alles äh nach Recht und Ordnung äh vorgeht. Inwieweit das jetzt nicht äh vorgegangen äh ist, können sie ja gleich ausführen. Mich würde jetzt vor allem auch interessieren.
Wie das für sie war und welche Erkenntnisse sie da gewonnen haben, mit wem hatten sie's denn auf einmal zu tun?
Also äh wenn man da beobachtet wird, wenn man unter Druck gesetzt wird, das sind ja jetzt nicht unbedingt das, was man so unter rechtsstaatlichen Mitteln verstehen wollen würde. Was hat sich da auf einmal für ein System äh für sie äh abgezeichnet? Welche.
Haben sich da auf einmal Bahn gebrochen.
Also ich habe sehr schnell die Erfahrung gemacht und zwar nicht,
erst bei der Verteidigung der Leute aus der RAF, sondern vorher brat siebenundsechzig, das war ja drei Jahre vorher, ähm.
Die das Umgehen des Staates, der staatlichen Macht, der staatlichen Gewalt,
vorlegt, auch der polizeilichen, aber auch der justiziellen Gewalt mit kritischer, aufmüpfiger äh Bevölkerung. Also äh
die die große Demonstration, die für meine äh Politisierung entscheidend gewesen ist, am zweiten Juni neunzehnhundertsiebenundsechzig vor der großen Oper. Da hat der Staat,
kann bekennender äh Maaßen äh nach militärischen Gesichtspunkten,
äh auf eine Demonstration reagiert und zwar das hieß damals Leberwursttakt
also an beiden Seiten zumachen durch Polizeikräfte und dann in der Mitte drauf schlagen. Also um diesen Kern da, wenn man so will, äh zu vernichten, jetzt nicht physisch zu vernichten, aber eben auch physisch anzugreifen. Äh und
so war, also war das äh immer wieder die Tacos und die Bereitschaftspolizei, die es hier in Berlin gegeben hat
haben Demonstrationen als
irgendwie einen Schandfleck angesehen, den man beseitigen muss. Und wir haben häufig demonstriert, jede Woche, mehrfach, immer damals am Kurfürstendamm und Biebung bis Marktstraßen
Äh wir haben äh die Erfahrung der staatlichen Gewalt gemacht und wir haben die Erfahrung gemacht, sehr viele von denen, die dann auch ins Gefängnis kamen. Ähm.
Dass sie ungerecht da drin saßen, das ist keine Beweismittel gab und dann viele, also für mich ist das immer das Schlimmste oder.
Schrecklichste heute noch, wenn ich dran denke, Beispiel war Holger Mainz.
In seiner Wohnung äh festgenommen worden ist unter dem Verdacht an einem Sprengkörper gebastelt zu haben, weil unter der Wohnung irgendwie so eine Rohrwerkstatt gewesen ist von irgendeinem Handwerker
Der saß drei Monate in Haft und wurde in der Haft, wenn er dem Richter vorgeführt wurde, immer von einem her, von Polizisten, die inzwischen sich hielten, dann da hingeführt
Nach drei Monaten wurde er ohne sang- und klanglos aus der Haft entlassen, war nix. Äh.
Was mit dem Menschen natürlich in dieser Zeit äh ungerecht eingesperrt passiert, habe ich erlebt, weil ich habe ihn häufig besucht im Gefängnis. Und das war eigentlich ein Einzelfall, sondern sehr viele. Wir standen gegenüber auch einer Justiz.
Die bis auf Ausnahmen sehr sehr parteiisch reagiert hat und das was ich heute den Leuten raten würde geht doch zum Bundesgerichtshof oder zum Bundesverfassungsgericht,
beim Bundesgerichtshof saßen wie gesagt noch alte Leute aus dem Reichsgericht.
Da haben wir, die haben wir unsere Schriftsätze mitten mit zwei Sätzen abgetan, wenn wir uns zehn Seite Mühe gegeben haben. Oder beim Bundesverfassungsgericht wurden die ganzen Beschwerden einfach nicht angenommen. Also wir standen eigentlich hilflos, dieser
diesen staatlichen Druck der staatlichen Gewalt gegenüber und diese Erfahrung, das sag ich jetzt mal als Erklärung, auch der Radikalisierung nachher
hat natürlich bei vielen der Studenten ähm.
Dazu beigetragen, äh dass sie irgendwann sagten, wir die einzige Lösung, die wir noch sehen, wie wir da weiterkommen, ist, äh dass wir uns mit Gewalt wehren.
Also im Prinzip war der Staat selber auch Mitschuld am Aufbau dieser Strukturen.
Der hat äh an dieser Schraube äh an dieser Schraube der Eskalation, äh der Repression und Gewalt und gegen Gewalt äh heftig mitgedreht.
Und warum.
Warum hat er das getan? Ist das Angst, ist das Hilflosigkeit? Ist das äh Berechnen des Verhalten? Sind die böse? Was.
Sie auf diesen Weg gebracht. Warum waren sie der Meinung, dass das der Weg ist, den man gehen sollte? Haben sie das.
Also warum ich der Meinung, also ich war der Meinung, weil ich äh sicher war, da muss sich was ändern. Und der warum der Staat so? Also damals hätte ich ihnen gesagt, äh.
Also ich war immer vorsichtig mit der Bezeichnung Faschismus, der alte Faschismus und andere haben das ständig im Munde geführt, ich habe das zurückhaltend, weil ich gesagt habe.
Ist nicht immer so, aber natürlich, das war altes Denken, das waren Leute, die auch aus der Generation kamen, die auch den Faschismus mitgemacht haben, zumindestens.
Äh und so haben wir vieles erklärt. Ich habe zum Beispiel während meiner Referendarzeit, das war neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig da äh neunzehnhundertachtundsechzig
äh habe ich äh ein Arbeitsgemeinschaftsleiter gehabt, bei dem ich Strafrecht gelernt habe, einem Richter.
Der saß gleichzeitig damals in einem Prozess, war er Vorsitzender eines Schwurgerichts, in dem der einzige Richter vom Volksgerichtshof, der jemals vor in Deutschland vor Gericht gestellt worden von den vielen Richter dieser im Volksgerichtshof gab.
Freigesprochen worden ist, weil die Terrorurteile, die die da Methodestrafe in zehn Minuten gefällt haben, vom Volksgerichtshof und in einer Viertelstunde, weil die als äh
wurde nicht bestritten, dass er daran beteiligt war. Es sondern es wurde gesagt, na ja, der hat sich an das damalige Recht gehalten.
Ne, also diese Erfahrung, die wir gemacht haben, die hat uns völlig verzweifeln lassen und gesagt,
Das ist die andere Seite, mit denen haben wir nichts zu tun, mit denen wollen wir nichts zu tun haben, wie die wollen wir bekämpfen.
Als es dann zu dieser Eskalation kam mit der RAF und die großen Prozesse äh liefen, Stammheim äh Prozess, wo sie ja auch beteiligt waren, auch mit.
Leuten wie Otto Schilli zum Beispiel, die ja später dann auch ganz andere Rollen äh eingenommen haben.
Da war das ja, wenn so, sagen wir mal, schon etwas ein etwas formalerer äh Krieg eben, haben wir jetzt noch von den frühen Repressionen gegen die Demos gesprochen,
war ja quasi die die Katze aus dem Sack so. Es gab diese offene Konfrontation einiger Gruppen aus dem Untergrund, die sich eben mit Gewalt wehren wollten, weil sie keine andere Wahl mehr sahen.
Auf der anderen Seite gab's jetzt diesen herausgeforderten äh Rechtsstaat, der sich jetzt gegen diese neu geschaffene Situation wehren wollte.
Welches also
ich weiß nicht, wie lange man das immer noch mit dieser alten Nazizeit und den alten Strukturen erklären kann. Auf der anderen Seite haben wir ja auch einen Start
gesehen, der auch äh durchaus Bemühungen und auch erfolgreiche Bemühungen gezeigt hat, über die Zeit, sich aus der alten Nazirolle zu befreien, ein freiheitliches System aufzusetzen, das war ja auch das Selbstverständnis, zumindest das offizielle Selbstverständnis äh der Bundesrepublik
wie haben Sie das empfunden? Wie hat sich das da niedergeschlagen? Gab's da auch Kräfte, die in die andere Richtung gingen? Oder.
Natürlich gab's auch andere ganz bekannte Leute, Heinrich Böller oder so, die sich ja auch sehr engagiert haben und auch versucht haben, Verständnis äh für äh dafür, dass Leute
jetzt keine anderen meinen, keinen anderen Weg mehr äh sehen zu können als äh zur Gewalt zu greifen. Ähm das gab's, das war gerade im,
ktuellen Bereich, bei Schriftsteller und so gab's eine ganze Menge, kann, könnte ich Ihnen viele Namen sagen.
Aber eher innerhalb des Staatsapparats.
Innerhalb der Staatsapparates haben wir einfach gesehen, dass.
Ist für die keine Alternative gab. Wenn ich versucht habe beispielsweise, da gab's ja immer große Hungersteigs, wo die Gefangenen
äh mir Rechte im Gefängnis und Zusammenlegung, Gefängnis und so weiter äh äh gekämpft haben unter Einsatz ihrer Gesundheit, sogar ihres Lebens. Äh.
Dass ich habe dann versucht beispielsweise, mit dem Staat, das heißt mit der Staatsanwaltschaft darüber zu reden, können wir das nicht so oder so machen
dann wurden mir Zusagen gegeben, damit der Hungerstreik abgebrochen wird äh und anschließend wurde das alles nicht eingehalten. Also der Staatsanwalt, mit dem ich telefoniert hatte und gesagt, also wenn sie da und so das regeln, dann äh
weiß ich, dann würden die wahrscheinlich aufhören oder so. Äh,
nachher bin ich dann bei meinen Mandanten erschienen. Die haben gesagt, hör mal, du hast uns doch versprochen, hast du mit dem Staatsanwalt da was geklärt, hast, dass sich da was ändert bei uns, bis heute hat sich nichts geändert, drei Wochen, vier Wochen sind rum. Ähm
Also wir sind verzweifelt an dem, äh wie der Staat reagiert hat und man darf ja nicht vergessen, der große Prozess in Stuttgart-Stammheim
ist vorbereitet worden. Der fing im Mai äh neunzehnhundertsieben äh neunzehnhundertfünfundsiebzig an
Der ist vorbereitet worden, neunzehnhundertvierundsiebzig durch ein ganzes Paket von Änderungen der Strafgesetze und der Strafprozessordnung, was in,
drei Tagen im Deutschen Bundestag durch die drei Lesung durchgepeitscht worden ist, damit es am ersten Januar neunzehnhundertfünf äh,
fünfundsiebzig dann in Kraft treten konnte. Also auch der Staat hat
allen äh Mitteln auch gesetzgeberischen Mitteln reagiert äh und soweit ich weiß, gab's damals im Deutschen Bundestag nicht eine Stimme, der jedenfalls erinnere ich mich nicht dran,
der Opposition dagegen zu sagen, mal langsam äh bevor wir solche weitgehenden Gesetze.
Beschließen, die zum Beispiel bedeuten, dass man auch Prozesse äh Strafprozesse ohne Angeklagte, dass sie auch im Gefängnis bleiben und führen kann und deren Rechte äh vornothin beschneiden, die Recht der Verteidigung beschnitten wurde. Das wurde äh.
Reagierte der Staat eigentlich so wie die Mandanten das immer vorhergesagt haben. Der Staat wird dann, äh so haben die das immer gesagt, die Fratze zeigen,
wenn er wirklich herausgefordert ist, ne? Wir standen dann da und mussten uns von dem Mandanten gefallen lassen, den Vorwurf, ihr seid die letzten, ja nee, also die Anwälte, ihr seid die letzten Jahren den Rechtsstaat glauben, weil guckt mal, wie die reagieren.
Dann irgendwann hat sich diese hat sich dieser Staat ja doch geändert. Ist äh ist das einfach nur weil die weil diese Kandidaten
weggestorben sind und die Eliten, sage ich mal, aus einer äh aus einer Sozialisierung an der an der Freien Universität Berlin und und aus dieser Bewegung dann irgendwann in die Anwalts
Post nicht nur in die Anwaltsposten, sondern auch natürlich in die Staatsanwaltsposten, in die Richterposten. In alle anderen elitären Posten hineinwuchs. War das der Grund, dass diese dass diese Welt sich geändert hat? Oder,
gab's da auch.
Ich glaube, also ich ich zweifel immer ran, daran, dass ich dass sich Dinge wirklich ändern, weil Menschen ähm in ihren Überzeugungen äh geändert
äh wurden also.
Das stimmt, also ich weiß jetzt von ganz wenigen nur, sagen wir mal, die da eine besonders harte äh repressive Rolle gespielt haben, die nachher dann ganz anders waren, also häufig
findet das zwar statt, bei Altersmilden, äh aber das war nicht ihr Grund. Natürlich hatte es was damit zu tun, ist eine neue Generation gewesen, andere Leute, die dahin kamen, ganz andere Ideen, die aufkamen, die plötzlich sogar in der Bevölkerung
immer mehr Anklang fahren, sogar mehrheitsfähig wurden, nehmen sie die ganze AKW-Frage. Äh als die Anfang mit den ersten
Demonstration gegen Atomkraftwerke, die wurden als verrückte Modernisierungsverweigerer äh dargestellt,
ne, die nur irgendwie Streit suchen, äh weil sie das äh große Gute, dass da doch ein äh
Mobili jetzt äh existiert, das ewig die Energien hat, äh die Arbeitskräfte zu ersetzen und so weiter, äh das.
Es gab es gab überhaupt keinen, kein Verständnis eigentlich äh für die und das hat sich dann geändert durch Leute
weil man einfach auch merkte, im Team hat ja Recht, wenn sie sich heute die Welt angucken, das was
vor den Grünen übrigens da war, was dann auch die Grünen sehr gefördert hat, viele Sachen, die sind heute, finden sie in allen Parteiprogrammen. Ne, also von Umweltschutz, Umweltbewegung, Anti-AKW, Energiewende,
Wenn damals einer gekommen wäre, hat gesagt, wir brauchen
Energiewende, wir holen nur noch den Strom ausm aus der Sonne und vom Wind und vom Wasser äh und alles andere brauchen wir nicht mehr. Die Kohle, wenn alles zu äh gemacht und ähm Öl brauchen wir auch nicht mehr. Das müssen wir alles ersetzen, weil's zu dreckig ist.
Die sie werden eingeliefert worden irgendwo in der Anstalt, weil weil sie irgendwie nicht begriffen haben, wo sie leben.
Aber eins scheint sich nicht geändert zu haben und das ist so diese ähm Reaktion äh des Staates auf diese Bedrohungssituation, zum Beispiel durch äh.
Terror, wie es immer so schön äh heißt. Das mag äh oft Terror sein, manchmal vielleicht auch nicht, das lasse ich.
Lassen sie mich dazu nochmal einsetzen. Ich habe ja vorhin schon in Vietnamkrieg erwähnt. Und was immer unterschlagen wird äh bei der Geschichte der RAF.
Dass die RAF, also die Strafverteidiger aus der damaligen Zeit, redet jetzt nochmal. Wir haben ja auch entsprechende Anträge im Prozess dann gestellt. Äh die ersten Anschläge der RAF, die mit Toten verbunden waren,
Gerichtet gegen die US-Hauptquartiere in Deutschland, von denen aus unter anderem der Vietnamkrieg geführt wurde.
Die Truppen der USA sind sehr,
häufig geliked worden über Deutschland, Hauptquartier in Frankfurt, Hauptquartier in Heidelberg. Äh das die spielt eine ganz strategisch wichtige Rolle und sie müssen sich das immer vorstellen. Der Krieg hat zehn Jahre gedauert,
Wir saßen, damals wurde gerade das Fernsehen kam so langsam in die Häuser. Bei uns
Zuhause war das lange nicht der Fall. Wir saßen aber dann nachher abends wirklich so vor dem Fernseher und sagen.
Im Namen unserer Freiheit, unseres Westens, werden da Flächenbombardements durchgeführt. Wir sahen ja, damals gab's
mit der Zensur hat man noch nicht so richtig hingekriegt. Wir sahen, wie die Leute da verbrannten auf der Straße, als brennende Fackeln durch die Gegend liefen, bei den Napalmbomben und äh
verzweifeln an der an der Welt. Und unser regierender Bürgermeister, nachher Bundeskanzler, Willy Brandt, äh,
hat mich ein einziges kritisches Wort jemals, jedenfalls kenne ich keins zum Vietnamkrieg gesagt.
Die äh die äh Glocke hier, der äh der Schöneberger Rathauses wurde in kleinen Exemplaren.
Äh gegossen und an die GIes in äh Vietnam verteilt, äh weil sie dort unsere Freiheit verteidigten.
Dass man sich für Augen fuhren, das ist, sonst ist das auch die ganze Radikalisierung äh und und Brutalisierung, die er an der die Skrupellosigkeit ist wirklich nur aus diesem
Ohnmacht, der unendlichen Wut, äh die daraus entstanden ist. Ich will das jetzt nicht sagen, das war gut oder so, aber das so erklärt sich das.
Es war ein ähm war das nicht auch ein entscheidendes Argument der Verteidigung bei dem Stammheimer
dass es eben nicht eine, also dass das eine dass das politisch motivierter Widerstand war und nicht äh einfaches.
An der an der Seite des Vietcong, das war ja die Befreiungsbewegung, da in Vietnam und äh es gab damals Berichte, dass äh
in Vietnam äh irgendwie äh plakatiert worden ist. Danke an die Genossen, die da in in in Deutschland die äh gegen diesen Krieg äh äh sich wenden.
Weil da haben wir ja auch wieder eine interessante äh Parallele, so diese Bündnistreue zu den äh USA, die ja zweifelsohne durch die ähm.
Niederringungen der der Naziherrschaft ihre äh Verdienste gehabt haben. Ohne Zweifel. Ähm.
Stand dann sehr hoch im Kurs, so die viel beschworene Freundschaft oder wie man das auch immer nennen möchte. Jetzt haben sie im Prinzip jetzt auch gerade gesagt, als Willy Brandt eben nicht kritisiert hat. Ähm gegenüber diesen Vorgängen, weil man ja.
Doch schon eine sehr schwache Position, glaube ich, damals äh gehabt hat, wie auch heute teilweise noch gegenüber dem politischen Einfluss.
Der USA. Das ist halt auch auch wieder so ein äh Ding, was wir auch heute sehen
grade jetzt im Fall um äh Snowden, aber ich wollte nochmal zurückkommen auf diesen,
Punkt, so wären so Umweltschutz und dieses Selbstverständnis äh da muss was geschehen und äh Atomkraft ist der falsche Weg, sich langsam,
durchgesetzt hat, sind diese Reaktionen auf Widerstand gegen den Staat gefühlt immer noch dieselben.
Nee, das ist eben nicht richtig. Ich will das nicht kleinreden, was auch heute. Ich,
nehmen wir ja immer noch an vielen Demonstrationen teil. Am Wochenende werde ich auch äh gegen NPD und äh weiter wieder auf der Straße sein. Ich fahre immer nach Dresden äh um dagegen äh gegen die NPD zu demonstrieren. Also ähm
natürlich machen die Demonstranten auch zum Teil schlimme Erfahrungen. Aber es gibt einen Unterschied.
Ähm es gibt hier immer wieder äh berechtigte Hoffnungen, dass man im gerichtlichen Verfahren vielleicht nicht in der ersten Instanz, aber in der nächsten Instanz nicht in allen Fällen, auch da gibt's weiter Ungerechtigkeit, aber doch in vielen Fällen ähm dann,
zu einigermaßen vertretbaren Urteilen kommt
für uns war das dieses äh hoffnungslose dann Rechtsmittel einzulegen und da gar keine richtige Reaktion drauf zu kriegen, das ist heute anders. Ich habe das mal vor ein paar Wochen
auch anlässlich einer Diskussion so formuliert
Der Bundesgerichtshof vor allen Dingen der politische, also der Senat, der für so diese politischen Sachen zuständig ist, äh und das Bundesverfassungsgericht damals die Rolle gespielt hätten, die sie heute spielen, ich will das nicht alles gut reden, aber.
Mit vielen äh positiven Sachen, dann hätte es auch in der damaligen Opposition und in der damaligen Gesellschaft möglicherweise andere Entwicklungen gegeben werden, die Entwicklung anders verlaufen.
Es waren diese Hoffnungslosigkeit in einem angeblichen Rechtsstaat äh sein Recht wirklich zu bekommen.
Also wir sind, wir haben quasi in den, in den Jahrzehnten die Entwicklung gemacht von Benno ohne Sorg wird auf der offenen Straße erschossen zu heute
kommen wir eventuell um äh juristische Repression in der zweiten Instanz herum, wenn wir uns bei einer Demonstration zu weit aus dem Fenster lehnen.
Also auch die ganze Geschichte mit Benno ohne Sorge und äh Freispruch von also dem Polizisten, der
äh gezielt dahin geschossen, na ja auf auf ihn geschossen hat, ne und den man inzwischen ja weiß, dass er außerdem noch für die Statiker gearbeitet hat. Äh also äh ja alles, wenn man sich das heute vor Augen führt, das kann man ja überhaupt nicht mehr
begreifen, dass sowas möglich gewesen ist, aber das war so. Nein, es hat sich was verändert.
Wahrscheinlich auch, weil das andere Richter eine andere Generation sind, äh die überhaupt das Grundgesetz.
Was damals ja auch schon gab und was fast genau so lautete wie heute, sogar zum Teil sogar im Asylparagrafen und sogar so freiheitlicher war, äh das Grundgesetz haben die neu entdeckt
die Gerichte dann, also vor allen Dingen des Bundesverfassungsgericht, Hamburg in einer Reihe von Entscheidungen, zum Beispiel auch zum Demonstrationsrecht, dann so langsam angefangen, dass äh zurechtzustürzen, zu sagen, doch.
Ein Recht auch in Brockdorf zu demonstrieren am Ort des AKW und äh die der Staat ist nicht berechtigt, die Leute dort.
Irgendwie kilometerweit zehn oder zwanzig Kilometer weit fern, sondern die haben Recht auch an den Bauzaun ranzukommen
äh solche Sachen äh das ist ja das Demonstrationsrecht. Ist man einem Objekt äh seiner Kritik, äh wogegen man demonstriert, auch da sein kann, weil
Sonst äh jibelt man das auch. Und so ist das in vielen dieser Bereichen geschehen. Nehmen sie die sehr, sehr fortschrittlichen Entscheidungen. Zum Beispiel ist Bundesverfassungsgericht etwa,
die Politik manchmal jetzt vor sich her treiben so in diesen gesellschaftlichen Fragen, Gleichstellung von Homosexualität äh homosexuellen Paaren und äh bis hin zur Adoption und
all dieser völlig undenkbar in den sechziger, siebziger Jahren, ne? Das äh da war der Geist, das Denken.
Nicht nur in der Justiz, ich will das nicht alles auf die Justiz schieben, sondern in der Gesellschaft war so, ne, wenn wer auf der Straße demonstriert haben
dann wurden wir da angebrüllt, geht auch rüber über die Mauer und haut auch ab und man darf nicht vergessen, also jemand wie der nur aussah wie Rudi Dutschke
Der wurde versucht von einer Menge vor Schöneberger Rathaus aufzuhängen, weil er so aussah, weil weil das ein äh.
Revolutionär war.
Nee, nee, weil also jetzt von von äh von der dem sogenannten Mann und der Frau auf der Straße, die da äh sich zu einer Demonstration versammelt hat. Also
Verhältnisse, die tatsächlich anders waren als sie jetzt heute sind.
Sind die Verhältnisse deswegen heute gut.
Nein, die sind überhaupt nicht gut und ich bin immer noch dafür, äh ganz entscheidende Dinge in unserem Staat zu ändern, äh bis das, ich bin ja jetzt nur lange Parlamentarier seit.
Neunzehnhundertachtundneunzig ununterbrochen äh und kriege das im Bundestag mit meine Kritik am Funktionieren der parlamentarischen Demokratie.
Ist ähnlich stark wie früher. Weil ich einfach sehe, dass vieles von dem, was wir in der Schule lernen oder in der Universität einfach gar nicht funktioniert so und.
Na ja, die die wichtigen Entscheidungen, die werden nicht in einer offenen Debatte, wo der eine den anderen überzeugt, im Plenum des Bundestages,
die Leute wundern sich immer, dass da so wenig Zuschauer sind. So wenig abgeordnete Zuschauer sind's ja meistens nur der Zuhörer. Ähm äh.
Das macht doch wenig Sinn, weil der Bundestag das Plenum des Bundestags ist so die Bühne, wo man.
Bereits beschlossen, jetzt von der Mehrheit beschlossene, nochmal fast Rituell darstellt, nach außen darstellt und die Opposition wendet sich dann dagegen und so, aber die Entscheidungen
die werden wir jetzt woanders.
Und doch halten sie dort äh immer wieder auch äh reden, die auch viel beachtet werden. Das heißt, da wie blicken sie auf eine solche Rede? Ist das im Prinzip nach außen hin vertreten ihrer politischen Position?
Werbung. Das ist Werbung für die politische Position.
Genau. Leider komme ich da viel zu wenig dran. Ich habe in der letzten Legislaturperiode
zu den Themen, äh die mir ungeheuer am Herzen liegen, also wie Vietnam liegt mir auch der Afghanistan-Krieg,
ungeheuer am Herzen, weil ich da von Anfang an dagegen war und immer sehr engagiert war und immer gesagt hat
Das dauert nicht nur ein halbes Jahr, wie das Schröder und Fischer gesagt haben oder höchstens ein Jahr, sondern inzwischen sind wir im zwölften Jahr äh und das ist ein richtiger Krieg geworden, was ja über lange Jahre einfach geleugnet worden ist. Das ist irgendwie so ein Aufbau äh Hilfsprogramm, was da läuft.
Und ich
wollte immer gerne dazu reden und durfte nicht reden. Auch das ist ja was, ähm die die äh solche kritischen Meinungen innerhalb von Fraktionen haben äh äh für die ist es äh unmöglich über ganze Legislaturperioden damit überhaupt zu Wort zu kommen
Es sei denn, also ich habe dann
Möglichkeiten äh der der Geschäftsordnung ausgenutzt, dass man eine Zwischenfrage stellen kann oder eine Zwischenintervention gibt's dann so, da darf man dann drei Minuten reden, aber da können sie dann natürlich wenig dazu sagen. Also ähm,
Ich kritisiere da vieles, weil es einfach nicht so ist, wie wir es lernen. Da muss vieles geändert werden. Äh aber äh.
Wenn ich jetzt politische Kritik unterbringen will, dann nutze ich natürlich die Möglichkeiten des äh des Parlaments. Das kann im Ausschuss sein, das kann
im Untersuchungsausschuss sein. Ich war all die Jahre fast stets in irgendeinem Untersuchungsausschuss. Äh das kann äh
aber natürlich auch im Plenum sein oder äh sonst in in dem im parlamentarischen Umgang.
Ich wollte mal genau auf diese auf diese Debatte und dieses Erreichen politischer Ziele nochmal zu sprechen kommen. Ähm ein Thema, was Sie ja sehr beschäftigt, was
uns auch am laufenden Meter äh beschäftigt bei uns im Programm, ist äh so die Frage der Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Die auch, sagen wir mal, von so einer kritischen Linken und äh netzgeneigten Szene, äh so ein bisschen als so die schwarze Pest
äh angesehen wird und wo es äh extrem starken Widerstand gibt, Ackervorrat und äh andere Gruppen haben sich da ja schon
äh sehr früh und sehr engagiert dagegen eingesetzt. Äh äh
es ist so ein bisschen wieder dieses und täglich größtes Murmeltier äh Effekt in dieser Debatte, dass immer wenn man das Gefühl hat, es ist jetzt irgendwie mal gerade wieder niedergerungen worden, dass sofort wieder dieselben
Stimmen wieder kommen und einfach immer wieder dasselbe fördern. Jetzt hatten wir gerade die Entscheidung beim europäischen Gerichtshof, die so im Wesentlichen äh
eine ähnliche, vergleichbar.
Position zumindest, wie das deutsche äh Verfassungsgericht eingenommen hat, in gewisser Hinsicht noch einen Schritt weiterging. Äh gleich die nächste Meldung war, der Vorsitzende der Polizeigewerkschaft fordert jetzt endlich die Einführung der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, weil jetzt wäre ja alles klar. Da fragt man
man sich dann immer so ein bisschen leben die in einer anderen Realität? Äh ist das einfach der politische Prozess
sämtliche Fakten zu ignorieren und äh stur an seinem äh Meinungen zu hängen und sich von Fakt
dabei nicht äh äh ablenken zu lassen äh ist es ein oder ist es einfach ein Missverständnis im politischen Diskurs, äh meinen die das einfach nur äh sind die alle nur ganz böse und und und min und wollen einem immer nur das Schlechteste man verzweifelt ein wenig
können sie uns mal so ein bisschen Einblick geben, wie sie das sehen, wie dieser politische Diskurs so im Großen und Ganzen eigentlich da äh zu interpretieren ist.
Also ich glaube gar nicht, dass das äh jetzt böse Menschen sind oder böser Wille ist von denen, sondern,
Seit Fuschi, in dem äh Minister äh der Französischen oder nach der französischen Revolution
Gibt es äh in der äh im exekutimen Regierungsbereich immer wieder Leute, die der Auffassung sind,
am besten alles über alle Menschen weiß, dann äh gibt es kein asoziales,
sogenanntes asoziales oder von den Regeln abweichendes Verhalten wäre
dann gibt's kein Verbrechen mehr, dann gibt's keine, werden keine Frauen von Männern mehr geschlagen, dann werden keine Kinder mehr, dann weiß man das ja alles, weil man
irgendwie äh das dann steuern kann und so frühzeitig eingreifen kann, dass die Menschen nur noch lieb miteinander umgehen. Da ist jetzt mal etwas überspitz,
äh und das war natürlich in Zeiten der Französischen Revolution ganz ganz weit weg, aber da fing das ja an mit Geheimdiensten und so, wo man sagte, man muss möglichst viel auch über die Genossen und so wissen, die da im Kampf sind. Und das hat.
Aus in meiner Zeit meiner Politisierung war das damals der Chef des Bundeskriminalamtes, Herr Herold. Äh der hat schon dieses System auch für Deutschland,
Die Nazis haben wahrscheinlich auch davon geträumt und die Stasi auch davon geträumt, aber das hat der hat für eine
Demokratie, für eine demokratische Gesellschaft auch davon geträumt und zwar hat der sehr früh begriffen, da gab's ja die Anfänge von Computern,
oder Viertelkästen und dann Computern. Wir müssen jetzt möglichst viel über die Leute,
rausbekommen da gibt's richtig Theorien dann von denen wie man damit dann die Bevölkerung kontrollieren kann und der hat in eine völlig abgeschlossenen Bereich beim Bundeskriminalamt gelebt wo der diese Ideen entwickelt hat.
Dieser Gedanke ist nicht tot, sondern der lebt mit den neuen, ungeahnten Möglichkeiten, heute der
Überwachung der neuen Form der Kommunikation Großteil, ich weiß nicht wahrscheinlich inzwischen Drittel oder sowas, der kommende Kommunikation der Menschen heute in Europa,
weiten Teilen der Welt spielt sich eben über äh die äh jetzt über den Äther, über Internet und ähnliches ab
Telefon und das eröffne natürlich ganz andere Möglichkeiten, man muss nicht immer ein da haben, man muss auch nicht ein Mikrofon da installieren und zu ursammern man kommt an die Liebesbeziehung, an,
Wutausbrüche an sonstiges Fehlverhalten, auch an natürlich auch an Straftat,
Verhalten. Sehr, sehr viel einfacher ran, indem man zu Hause an irgendeinem Computer sitzt und sich die Daten einsammeln lässt. Und ich muss ja auch sagen, auch ich selber bin natürlich von dieser Entwicklung völlig überrollt,
äh also als ich zum ersten Mal im Bundestag war, äh da haben die Grünen darüber gestritten, äh ob man PCs anschaffen soll.
In den achtziger Jahren und haben Beschluss gefasst, das kommt das Teufelszeug kommt bei uns nicht in die Büros rein, ne? Äh so.
Damals hat der CCC noch dieses Gutachten dafür geschrieben.
Nee, nee, nee, das war für das achtziger Jahre, dreiundachtzig oder vierundachtzig,
also äh das muss ich ja sehen und ich bin von dem auch aber ich erkläre natürlich in meinem eigenen Verhalten um mich rum überall, dass sich die Welt,
total verändert hat. Und das ist natürlich jetzt neue Möglichkeiten gibt, aber auch natürlich neue Möglichkeiten, diese alte Idee.
Die Bevölkerung zu kontrollieren
zu revitalisieren und da ist die NSA jetzt das super Osterbeispiel, die das machen. Wobei ich ja auch aus der NSA weiß, dass da ein Kampf zweier Linien,
geführt worden ist bis zweitausendeins, wo die der eine Teil gesagt hat, nein.
Wir müssen Terrorismus, organisierte Kriminalität gezielt.
Bekämpfen, indem wir gezielt äh bei Verdachtsmomenten und so weiter vorgehen, während der andere gesagt hat, nein, wir müssen alles.
Sammeln und dann gucken wir und dann von all dem Gesamt, dann gucken wir da rein, wo könnte da was sein, äh äh was äh verdächtig ist, ne? Ist ja ein völlig anderer Herangehensweise und die sind dann den Weg gegangen.
Da gab's 'ne richtige Entscheidung darüber, sind dann den Weg gegangen zu sagen wir machen das so, dass wir alles und deshalb
damals hat man dann noch darüber gelacht, noch zweitausendeins, weil da war ich ja auch schon im Bundestag, war ja auch schon
PKG und war vor allen Dingen auch in der Koalition, wo man dann darüber redete, auf ein neues
Gesetz brauchen und so. Da war das alles noch graue Theorie. Da hat selbst das Bundesverfassungsgericht
gesagt, es könnte mal irgendwann die Zeit geben, dass man unendlich viele Informationen sammelt und auswerten, so, aber das ist noch weit, weit weg. Ne, inzwischen ist das, was damals weit weg war, Realität um uns rum
Das ist, glaube ich,
dieser Kampf äh zu sagen, man muss möglichst viel über alle wissen, auch die gar nichts Böses tun oder jedenfalls nicht, was so Kriminelles tun.
Das muss man alles wissen, erst dann kann man Vorsorge treffen, das kontrollieren und da streitet sich dann eben die Polizeigewerkschaft mit einer gewissen Logik, die sagt für uns aus unserer Sicht ist die Abwehr von Verbrechen, von Fehlverhalten,
oberste Gebot aller Dinge und dann könnte eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung auch mal helfen.
Und natürlich haben sie dann immer Beispiele, wo das auch mal geholfen hat und so äh und.
Die andere ist eben, wo kommen wir da hin, äh dann kann man sich nicht mehr frei fühlen, man kann nicht mehr frei kommunizieren, das geht äh ja nicht nur.
Dass man sich vor zu schützen versucht, sondern man traut sich bestimmte Sachen gar nicht mehr zu äußern
ne? Die Selbstkontrolle ist ja eigentlich das Gefährlichste bei dieser Geschichte, äh die dann um sich greift und sagt, äh uh, lieber nicht sagen und äh so, ne, das
und und diese beiden Linien, äh die kämpfen jetzt miteinander und da ist die Frage, wer setzt sich da durch auch in der Allgemeine in der Gesellschaft? Und da ist die Vorratsdaten
Speicherung jetzt ein Beispiel äh an dem dazu ausgetragen wird.
Das Problem ist doch wahrscheinlich, dass diese,
beiden Positionen eigentlich durch Überzeugung und Argumentation jetzt nicht irgendwie einander näher zu bringen sind, oder? Also ich denke, also ich habe.
Bin jetzt gerade, was die Position der der CDU und auch jetzt der SPD leider angeht zur relativ schockiert das nämlich,
In Reaktion darauf, dass jetzt zwei,
höchste Gerichte. Jeweils solche Gesetze einkassiert haben. Deutsche Bundesverfassungsgericht und der äh Europäische Gerichtshof. Ähm in Reaktion darauf liest man dann so eine Meldung, dass ähm einige
Politiker, der, der, oder einige Unionspolitiker, sich nun Gedanken darüber machen.
Wie man denn dieses aus dem Band, aus dem Ruder gelaufene Bundesverfassungsgericht irgendwie wieder auf Linie bringt. Ja, also.
Erkennen ja, dass es da ein Problem gibt, die erkennen es gibt ein Problem, das Bundesverfassungsgericht ist gegen unsere Gesetz-Ideen. Ähm sie erkennen aber nicht im nicht im geringsten an.
Vielleicht das die Gesetze, die vielleicht nicht ganz so gut war. Bisschen mal wenigstens drüber nachgedacht werden sollte. Ähm,
dann ist doch so eine, so ein Parlamentsgedanke doch totaler, also es das wird ja zu nix führen. Ich meine, wenn selbst,
ein Korrektiv außerhalb des Parlamentes inzwischen schon äh unter Berufung auf auf Verfassungen. Diese Richtlinien einsackt und das wird,
Einfach weiter diskutiert, ungeachtet aller, um aller Drumherum geschehenen Tatsachen.
Dieser Kampf wird wahr immer weitergehen, weil die einen sagen.
Selbst wenn mein Kommunikationsverhalten dadurch oder dass der ganzen Bevölkerung eingeschränkt wird, äh das nehmen wir in Kauf.
Ähm viele haben ja auch nichts gegen autoritäre Regierung, muss man ja auch sagen. Äh das gibt uns mehr Sicherheit.
Und die anderen sagen, das Wichtige ist
für die menschliche Entwicklung insgesamt auch für die Fortentwicklung von der Wissenschaft bis zum bis zur Philosophie der Literatur in allen
ist die Freiheit des der Entwicklung des Geistes. Das ist ein Kampf, der wird immer weitergehen und da ist immer die Frage, wer setzt sich durch? Und das sind übrigens auch
Grade zwei Beispiele, wo das Bundesverfassungsgericht schon seit der äh Volkszählungsentscheidung
über die ich mich damals, ich war da sehr engagiert in der Anti-Volks-Selungsbewegung äh sehr gefreut habe und vorher das nicht für möglich gehalten habe, wo es sich wieder zeigt, dass dieses Gericht
Professoren überwiegen, drin sitzen, die die Verfassung auslegen und die Verfassungsideen ernst nehmen, äh tatsächlich Fortschritt mit,
bewirkt haben, also jedenfalls unterstützt haben. Und Gesellschaftsfähig gemacht haben, vor allen Dingen, wenn das vom Bundesverfassungsgericht sagt, ähm das ist äh ähm,
das muss so sein, dass äh ergibt sich auch in unserer Verfassung, ist das noch ein hat das noch eine andere Qualität, als wenn Ströbele da sagt, ne?
Aber wenn dieser Kampf immer weitergehen wird, ähm.
Was ist dann die was lenkt dann also lenkt nicht eine andere Kraft, nämlich die böse Kraft im Prinzip das oder Böses jetzt übertrieben, aber die die gegnerische Kraft lenkt ja den den Diskurs immer wieder dahin. Ja, also es wir.
Ja, die werden das immer wieder versuchen und äh je nachdem, wie die gesellschaftliche Situation ist, werden sie sich auch wieder durchsetzen.
Also nehmen wir mal an, irgendwas ähnliches wie der elfte neunte zweitausendeins geschieht jetzt nochmal, dann wird, wie das damals ja auch war, ich habe das ja sehr, sehr miterlebt, damals in der Mitte erlebt
die Folgen, in der rot-grün äh Regierung, da konnte man über Datenschutz und wer das Wort überhaupt in den Mund genommen hat, der wurde schon irgendwie als äh als halber Sympathisant angesehen oder so, ne. Also die werden auch wieder irgendwann Rückenwind kriegen. Das sehen sie jetzt bei der Entwicklung mit Ukraine, wo plötzlich
alte äh Vorurteile und so weiter wieder aufbrechen und man gegenseitig jetzt sich bedroht, mit Kriegs Kriegsszenarien, wo man eigentlich
das ist aus menschlichen Denken verschwunden. Ist überhaupt nicht, sondern äh das ist die Hochzeit des Kalten Krieges, mindestens des Kalten Krieges,
Wenn ich auch äh vor Kriegszeiten muss man sagen, die da ihr fröhliche Urstände feiern jetzt bei.
Bei dieser ganzen Diskussion. Und so ähnlich wird das, die werden auch wieder Oberwasser kriegen. Das wird nicht immer in die eine Richtung weitergehen, ne?
Und das führt doch dann bei vielen Menschen jetzt äh unserer Generation äh zu dem Phänomen, was allgemein als Politikverdrossenheit bezeichnet.
Das heißt, ähm dass dass Menschen sich von dem Ganzen politischen Theater.
Wenden, weil sie weil sie erstens genau das sagen, was sie gerade selbst äh sagten, in dem Parlament findet nicht mehr die Meinungsfindung und die Gestaltung der Politik statt und.
Also im Plenum nicht, in den Ausschüssen ist schon ähm da können ja auch die verschiedenen Interessen und die äh Abgeordnete, die jetzt Interessen dezidiert vertreten, sich auch viel offener
äh dann zuahnen. Das kommt nicht in Betracht und so äh austragen, ne?
Rückfrage zu Sie sagen die Interessen. Ist das nicht.
Wahrscheinlich das Hauptproblem äh des gesamten parlamentarischen Apparates, dass darin eigentlich Interessen vertreten werden, weniger als wirklich sagen wir so was wie Werte, Ideen, Ideale, Überzeugungen.
Ja natürlich, also das fängt ja damit an, dass man gewählt werden muss. Und gerade für die äh zu denen ich ja
Erfreulicherweise gehöre die direkt gewählt werden. Äh da muss ja äh die diese Person muss sich ja im Wahlkampf und auch vorher so öffentlich äh,
positionieren oder sich von sich auch ein Bild vermitteln, dass die Leute dazu bringt, den zu wählen, den und nicht die andere oder den anderen, ne? Und das ist ja häufig auch eine Frage
wie welchen Zugang hat man mit der Öffentlichkeit, wie viel Geld hat man zur Verfügung und so,
wer fördert einen und so, ne? Und,
Natürlich ist das alles miteinander äh verquickt und das wird man auch nie abschaffen, sondern da gibt's den Grundsatz auch des Grundgesetzes zu sagen
Wir können äh Spenden nicht verhindern, wollen wir auch nicht. Aber es muss öffentlich sein. Der Wähler, die Wählerin muss wissen, von wem der seine Spenden kriegt, ne?
Oder wie wie der dahin kommt. Also natürlich wird es immer Interessen geben, auch Interessenvertreter, wie offen und die, die dann äh artikuliert werden, das äh ist, glaube ich, hängt dann auch davon ab, in welchem Kreis die das ausgetragen wird.
Aber wir wissen ja zum Beispiel, diese äh meiner Ansicht nach verhängnisvoll falschen Entscheidungen bei den verschiedenen Rettungsschirmen jetzt in der äh Finanzkrise ähm,
das da die Kanzlerin dann den Chef der Deutschen Bank anruft als Hauptberater. Also machen die ja gar keinen Hehl draus, ne?
Und offenbar einen direkten Zugang hat an so, ne? Dann kann man sich vorstellen, äh was für eine Entscheidung dabei rauskommt.
Also da welche Interessen da an erster Stelle sind.
Nochmal kurz auf das Phänomen der Politikverdrossenheit äh zurück. Ich blicke auf diese Entwicklung.
Die sich jetzt in meiner Lebenszeit irgendwie abspielen schon und ähm dieser Gedanke der Politikverdrossenheit ist mir nicht nicht fern.
Ja, also ich kann das äh ich kann diese Menschen verstehen und ich bin selber äh immer mal wieder jetzt gerade mit dem Netzpolitischenbereich setze ich mich jetzt äh seit Jahren täglich äh bis ins Detail auseinander, dass ich manchmal denke,
ähm eigentlich könnte ich das auch lassen und mir irgendwie ein Hobby ein anderes Hobby zulegen, ja. Ähm.
Und viele Menschen machen auch genau das. Und dann gibt's aber Menschen wie sie, die das über Jahrzehnte durchhalten, diese Grabenkämpfe an vorderster Front mitzuführen und selber darüber zu sagen, natürlich werden die nie enden.
Wie kriegt man die Motivation?
Ja vielleicht ähm steckt dahinter, dass äh ich meine, dass es die Aufgabe der Menschheit äh zu der ich mich auch zähle. Ähm.
Sich fortzuentwickeln und dazu gehört eben auch, diese wahrscheinlich, wie sie richtig sagen, die aufhörende.
Auseinandersetzung darüber und das setzt immer voraus, dass es viele, ich sage mal, möglichst viele gibt, ähm die die Weiterentwicklung,
der Gesellschaft auch betreiben müssen, mich treibt, das mindestens so an
Fußballspieler, äh dass er in der Bundesliga bleibt oder dass er ähm den Cup äh mitgewinnt, ne. Ähm das gucke ich mir im Fernsehen an und habe ich am nächsten Tag oder im nächsten Stunde wieder vergessen
aber.
Wenn ich Aufgaben sehe, wo man äh wo ich was tun kann, wo ich eingreifen kann, wo ich mich engagieren kann und vielleicht ein bisschen mithelfen kann, was zu bewegen in die richtige Richtung.
Dafür lebe ich und das wird mich so lange antreiben, wie ich äh kaufen kann, wie ich einigermaßen gesund bin.
Was sind denn die großen Cups, auf die sie als Fußballer zurückblicken können?
Also wo ich, da mache ich gar keinen Hehl draus, stolz bin, weil ich das selber auch nie für möglich gehalten habe, ist zum Beispiel, dass ich ähm die.
Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in meinem Wahlkreis zum ersten Mal aus einer völlig hoffnungslosen Position heraus.
Davon überzeugen konnte, mich zu wählen und dass das jetzt viermal wieder gelungen ist, ne?
Das ist natürlich, also wenn ich das schreibe ich auch immer den Leuten, die mir jetzt sagen, also du gehörst schon lange in Sarg und äh weiß ich was, ist schon alles überholt und,
deine dumme Fresse im Fernsehen nicht mehr sehen, gibt's ja auch, jeden Tag kriege ich so den schreibe ich dann immer so ganz nett und freundlich zurück
Wissen sie, das mag ja ihre Meinung sein, aber die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung in meinem Wahlkreis ist da anderer Meinung und nach das grade im letzten September zum Ausdruck gebracht. Natürlich.
Zeigt mir das, dass sehen viele Leute so und sagen auch viele die,
bei einzelnen Forderungen mit mir, wenn ich die treffe, auf der Straße in Kreuzberg in Friesheim oder Prenzlauer Berg sagen, aua, da hast du wieder nur Scheiß gemacht und das machste falsch und nicht. Aber insgesamt, da bist du mal richtig, ne?
Das ist natürlich was äh wo ich auch glaube ähm,
und das ist bei mir sogar eine Veränderung in der Wahrnehmung äh jetzt der der Menschen der Bevölkerung, dass die Bevölkerung.
Sehr häufig ungeheuer vernünftig reagiert. Also nehmen Sie mal im Augenblick.
Dem sie sie wählt.
Nee, Jan, das ist jetzt das ist natürlich auch richtig.
Aber nee, ich meine es jetzt zum Beispiel diese Diskussion, die wir jetzt haben in dieser über Ukraine und die Kriegs und Gewaltfrage und Bündnisfragen, was da alles eine Rolle spielt
da hat äh die große Masse der Bevölkerung, da zeigen die sich häufig sogar äh auch resistent gegenüber einem ziemlich geschlossenen öffentlichen Meinung, äh
hat da
für meine Beurteilung, ich habe da wenig dazu beigetragen, mal einen Eintrag bei bei Twitter oder bei Facebook bei mir, aber den lesen ja doch nicht so viele, äh ne vernünftige Auffassung, wo ich sagen kann.
Da kann man doch anknüpfen und alle die, die sagen, Demokratie ist schlecht, weil dann setzt sich letztlich nur irgendwie äh das Schlechte durch oder alle wollen nur viel Geld haben oder so. Äh ähm,
Das stimmt nicht, sondern hier ist offenbar ein Gefühl in der Bevölkerung, aus vielen Gründen und bei vielen auch unterschiedlich. Wo ich sage, ist prima, da kann man weiter mitarbeiten.
Aber ihre Position als äh als Parlamentarier mit Direktmandat ist ja schon auch eine sehr ähm
ungewöhnliche und vor allem ungewöhnlich komfortable, oder? Also ich andere ihrer Kollegen können da nicht, auf was ist ihre Mehrheit vierzig, fünfzig Prozent inzwischen in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg?
Ja, neununddreißig Komma neun beim letzten Mal, aber davor hatte ich schon mal sechsundvierzig.
Sechsundvierzig,
so mit mit so einem robusten Mandat äh gehen ja wenige äh in in das Parlament. Ja, das heißt, sie können sich zum Beispiel auch aus.
Diesen ganzen ähm.
Ökosystem Listenplatz irgendwie äh komplett raushalten. Sie brauchen ihn können in der Partei auch mal äh strikt eine eigene andere Meinung vertreten zum Afghanistan-Krieg. Das äh war, glaube ich, das.
Besondere Beispiel oder
immer wieder zitierte Beispiel dessen, dass sie halt alleine gehen und und vielem ähm Parlamentarier und viele Theoretiker plädieren ja auch dafür, dass wir wieder mehr zu diesem Modell,
unabhängigen Parlamentariers äh kommen, desjenigen, der sich nicht einem äh Fraktionszwang unterwirft, ähm andere sehen dadrin eine große Gefahr, Weimarer Zustände. Ähm aber es ist klar, dass.
Das Konzept Hans-Christian Ströbele auch genau deshalb funktioniert, weil in der Abgrenzung zu dem, was wir überall sonst sehen.
Oder äh gehe ich damit zu weit?
Nö, natürlich, also ich habe,
seit ich dieses Direktmandat habe, natürlich eine viel größere Unabhängigkeit, auch von, sagen wir mal, Augenblicksmeinungen
auch in der eigenen Partei als ich das vorher hatte.
Wobei nicht richtig ist die Wahrnehmung von außen, dass ich da irgendwie so ein Einzelkämpfer bin, also
Mein Kreisverband zum Beispiel, die sind immer zu achtzig, neunzig, über neunzig Prozent teilen die das, was ich mache, sonst würde ich's auch gar nicht machen. Ähm und auch auf
es wird auch immer übersehen
Positionen sind häufig Minderheitenpositionen, für die ich mich einsetze, aber das sind dann vierzig Prozent oder zweiundvierzig oder so, ne. Das heißt, das ist schon äh auch eine große Unterstützung auch zum Afghanistan, ne, die äh es hat keine Partei hinge,
das aus der Basis ein Sonderparteitag erzwungen ist gegen das gesamte Partei Establishment zum Afghanistan-Krieg und dann da einen Beschluss gefasst hat.
Der.
Entgegensetzt zu dem war, den der damalige Bundesvorstand vorgeschlagen hat, also äh wo ich mich dann natürlich ungeheuer wohl fühle und auch unterstützt fühle, obwohl ich vorher der Meinung sein konnte, oh ich bin gar nicht mehr auf der Seite der Mehrheit äh meiner Partei, ne. Also
ähm sie haben recht, äh das ist nicht nur schön am Wahltag, sondern auch danach und ich sage ihnen aber auch, selbst die
Position im Bundestag, also wenn ich mit Kollegen jetzt umgehe, aus anderen Parteien, auch der CSU, seit ich ein Direktmandat habe, werde ich von den,
CSU-Leuten, die da in Bayern irgendwo sechzig Prozent oder so äh an äh mit da reingewählt worden sind.
Werde ich als gleichberechtigter Partner.
Einer von ihnen, ja.
Nein, die, die sagen einfach, äh wie kommt man sonst ins Parlament, indem man irgendwie in dem Parteiengefüge äh auch einen guten Listenplatz kommt
warum auch immer. Äh das ist noch ein Unterschied, als wenn man sich wirklich dem eigenen Wählerschaft stellen muss und die dann sagen, okay, unter den Zehen, die da direkt kandidieren, wähle ich den aus, ne.
Ich mit jetzt so zum ähm Abschluss nochmal auf dieses Verhältnis äh Bürgerstaat kommen und zwar im Hinblick.
Die Geheimdienste, ein Thema, was uns ja äh alle im letzten Jahr extrem beschäftigt halt, was äh bei ihnen ja auch, wie wir schon gehört haben, wieder auch ganz zurück reicht bis in die Sechziger, siebziger Jahre
Und die grundsätzliche Frage, die sich uns und ich glaube auch vielen unseren Hörern immer wieder stellt ist.
Wie sollte das Verhältnis sein zwischen dem Transparentenstaat und dem geheimen Staat? Es ist halt einfach so,
System, in das wir jetzt so geboren sind und man sieht das ja auch in allen anderen Staaten, Geheimdienste gibt's überall, man hat eine Verfassungsschutz, man hat im BND, man hat den MAD, das ist irgendwie Teil davon und das politische Establishment
rechtfertigt halt die Existenz dieser Systeme als notwendig als alternativlos wie auch immer. Auf der anderen Seite
haben wir auch immer wieder viele Fälle, wo einfach Konflikte entstehen, einfach natürlich aus dieser geheimen Tätigkeit heraus,
sich, die einfach natürlich alles andere schafft, als äh Transparenz, wo man dann eben auch sehr viel Verschwörung äh mutmaßt,
ob die dann nun stimmen oder nicht, lässt sich halt alles sehr schwer überprüfen. Und auch das Gremium, in dem sie ja nun schon lange sind, seit fünfzehn Jahren, das äh parlamentarische Kontroll.
Gremium. Früher hieß es ja mal PKK, das fand ich eigentlich viel schöner.
Ich auf meinen Wunsch äh oder meine Intention wurde das dann geänder.
War da gar nicht so unzufrieden. Ich das überrascht mich jetzt aber. Na gut, also das PKG ähm.
Was ja auch so ein bisschen absurd ist, weil da zwar gewählte Abgeordnete äh sich mit den Geheimdiensten auseinandersetzen kann, aber ja darüber eigentlich quasi nichts in die Öffentlichkeit gelangt.
Also mich würde natürlich erstmal ihre persönliche Sicht sehen, wie sie so die Geheimdienste äh sehen, aber natürlich auch versuchen zu verstehen, wie.
Was diese Akzeptanz, dieses Systems ausmacht und und ob es da wirklich eine Notwendigkeit gibt dafür.
Also natürlich äh passt ein das ist ja ein Teil der Verwaltung.
Des Staates, der staatlichen Tätigkeit, der vor den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern geheim ist, nicht in eine offene Demokratie
das ergibt sich schon aus dem Wort Geheimdienst, deshalb wehren die sich ja auch immer dagegen und sagen, wir sind gar kein Geheimdienst, sondern Nachrichtenstil. Wir schaffen nur Informationen ran und äh stellen die dann der Politik zur Verfügung.
Also so was wie Twitter. Es wird ja auch mal als Nachrichtendienst bezeichne.
Ja ähm das passt eigentlich nicht zusammen
Ich habe mich auch immer dafür eingesetzt, gibt viele Äußerungen von mir schon aus den achtziger Jahren und vorher, dass ich gesagt habe, Geheimdienste äh
müssen abgeschafft werden. Ich bin auch heute noch der Auffassung, äh dass äh so wie die heute die Geheimdienste sind in dieser Gesellschaft, wie wir sie äh weiterentwickeln wollen, wie sie haben wollen, nicht reinpasst.
Ich nehme aber zur Kenntnis, dass aus vielerlei Gründe, es gibt sogar Gründe dabei, die auch ähm also wo ich auch sage, da ist was dran. Ähm.
Dass das nicht real ist. Also, dass morgen die alle zugemacht werden und das Geld woanders ausgegeben wird, ist sehr unwahrscheinlich. Äh, dass wie sie richtig sagen, wird das in anderen Ländern überhaupt nicht in Frage gestellt, ne. Also ich stelle das weiter in Frage, aber ich sage.
Wenn es die gibt, dann müssen wir diesen Geheimdienst möglichst viel dieses besonderen, das geheim nehmen,
Das heißt, wir müssen sie viel, viel transparenter gestalten. Das äh fängt schon bei den Diensten selber an, äh dass äh,
Das war ja früher sowieso viel, viel schlimmer noch. Da wusste man ja nicht mal, wie die Chefs heißen und ob die einen Schlapphut tragen und wie die aussehen und wo die äh.
Wo die überhaupt stationiert sind. Das war alles geheim. Genauso wie die angebliche Kontrolle geheim war. Man wusste nicht mal, wann getagt wird und wo getagt wird, von dem Gremium und so weiter
Also ich bin da es sehr, sehr viel mehr Offenheit äh äh und Transparenz möglich. Da können wir übrigens auch aus den USA lernen.
Im US-Kongress ist da sehr viel zum Teil, sage ich sogar fast schon zu viel.
Kooperation mit den Geheimdiensten durch die Kontrolleure der Geheimdienste, weil die so nah an den dran sind,
dass ich fürchten würde, ich äh drücke das mal ganz vorsichtig aus, dass es dann schon so eine fast so eine gewisse Kumpanei gibt oder sowas. Das darf natürlich auch nicht sein, aber sehr, sehr viel mehr Transparenz. Das heißt, die Dienste müssen transparenter sein.
Der ganz überwiegende Teil der der Tätigkeit, die die haben, äh muss überhaupt nicht geheim sein. Äh das ist also die Information, die die sammeln
Also zum Beispiel der Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz sind ja bekanntermaßen zu über achtzig Prozent aus normal zugänglichen Quellen, wo sie es einfach zusammenstellen von Zeitungsartikeln bis zu sonstigen Sachen,
wo auch die Antifa oder so drankommt. Ähm also das äh ist überhaupt nicht notwendig, dass man das alles als zu Geheime tragt. Und da bleibt ein kleiner Rest, also beispielsweise im Spionageabwehrbereich
zum Beispiel ich jetzt der Meinung bin, da müssten die eigentlich was machen, auch bei der NSA, äh das steht im Gesetz. Äh eigentlich muss der Deutsche Spionageabwehrdienst sich
darum kümmern. Mindestens jetzt, wo er erfahren hat,
die äh hier die gesamte Bevölkerung aussperren, müsste er genau dasselbe, was er gegenüber Russland oder China oder anderen Ländern, wo man schon immer davon ausging
dass sie in Deutschland spionieren, wo auch hin und wieder welche verurteilt worden sind, ähm müssen die da auch ihre Aufgabe wahrnehmen. Also da gibt's dann einen kleineren Bereich, wo man das vielleicht nicht so zum Markte bringt,
und da muss dann eine effektive Kontrolle äh des Parlaments äh einsetzen. Ähm die aber auch wiederum nicht so geheim sein kann.
Der Abgeordnete aber überhaupt nicht drüber reden kann, wenn er was erfährt, nicht mal seinen Fraktionsvorsitzenden. Also wenn ich von irgendeinem Skandal erfahren würde im PKG, was, glaube ich, noch nie der Fall gewesen ist, dann kann ich äh nur zu meinem Fraktionsvorsitzenden gehen und
sagen, da gibt's einen großen Skandal, den da äh darf ich euch aber nicht sagen, aber,
meine, wir müssen jetzt den Untersuchungsausschuss einrichten da an der Tür, weil da riesen, die Hütte brennt oder so, ne? Ist völlig absurd.
Dass man das nicht darf, ne? Aber das ist bisher noch nicht gelungen, das abzuschaffen, das heißt auch diese Kontrolle müsste man effektiv machen, weil das, wie's im Augenblick läuft, äh das ist.
Wesentlichen darauf angewiesen, dass wir Informationen bekommen, auch aus den Medien, weil findige Journalisten.
Oder der Chaos-Computer-Club irgendwas rausgekriegt hat und wir danach fragen und dann bohren. Und dann wissen die was sagen. Und dann widerspricht sich das und dann entsteht daraus ein Untersuchungsausschuss. Und dann kriegt man sehr, sehr viel mit.
Diese Tätigkeit, für die ich viel Zeit investiere, ist deshalb so wichtig.
Weil wenn die Dienste, das war ja früher alles mal anders, auch bei früheren Diensten, bei der Stasi sowieso, wenn die Dienste damit rechnen müssen, dass ihr Verhalten einfach nur damals wird, nicht immer passieren.
Da das ihr Verhalten sie irgendwann rechtfertigen müssen, nicht nur vor ihren Vorgesetzten, sondern in einem Parlamentsausschuss, auch vor der Öffentlich
wie das hier jetzt gewesen ist, auch bei den NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss oder vorher hatten wir einen BND-Untersuchungsausschuss, dann hat das eine erzieherische Wirkung, äh die weit über den Einzelfall hinausgeht.
Ich äh weiß auch aus den Diensten, dass das tatsächlich eintritt, ne, dass die sich dann überlegen, also,
Also wenn wir das und das jetzt machen äh und ich stehe dann irgendwo mal da und muss dann.
Ja, also ähm man kann das alles viel besser machen. Das, was wir im Augenblick machen, ist nicht sinnlos, weil das Beispiel hafte Sachen gibt.
Auf die wir kommen, gekommen sind, fast ausschließlich durch Artikel im Spiegel, AT
in der Süddeutschen Zeitung oder findigen äh zum Beispiel, also tatsächlich auch Chaos Computerclub, wo wir auf Sachen gekommen sind, gesagt, da haben wir gesehen und jetzt wollen wir mal dazu einen Bericht haben. Dass die von selber aus uns
auf die Skandale in ihren Diensten hinweisen. Das ist so gut wie.
Ich wollte nochmal nachfragen. Sie meinten, es gäbe ja auch Argumente für die Geheimdienste. Haben sie aber nicht äh genannt.
Die Spionage zum Beispiel. Also ähm.
Oder.
Spionageabwehr. Also, wenn Sie jetzt wissen, nehmen wir mal an, Sie hätten das alles nicht, alles weg und da gibt's jetzt nur die Polizei. Ähm.
Dann wird sehr schnell das eintreten, das was wir sowieso in der Entwicklung haben, die bedrohlich ist bei der Polizei, dass sie ja sehr viele auch so geheime Befugnisse hat,
also abzuhören und so weiter, äh die eigentlich sie gar nicht kriegen sollte, ne. Äh und das würde dann sehr viel mehr sich so entwickeln, dass die äh dass Teile der Polizei,
der Kriminalpolizei.
Der Staat äh äh Schutzdeliktpolizei äh sich zu sowas entwickeln, weil wir wollen natürlich auch nicht, dass jetzt einer dann ganz frech hier alles macht äh irgendeine Botschaft oder irgendeiner.
Positiv ausgedrückt, Geheimdienste beschützen vor allem die Polizei davor, sich zu sehr mit geheimer Aktivität zu beschäftigen.
Ja, äh solange wir der Poli äh darum kämpfen, nicht immer erfolgreich, dass die Polizei.
Nicht äh wieder äh Teile entwickelt, die mal also geheime Staatspolizei, die äh die ganzen Geheimbefugnisse hat
und dann noch Exekutivbefugnis hat. In Deutschland haben wir das ja getrennt
Information sammeln und das Exekutiv aus gutem Grund, aus diesen Gründen raus, solange wir das hochhalten und ich finde das eine hohe Errungenschaft.
Predige das auch in England oder so. Den Kollegen und sage, das müsstet ihr auch so machen. Äh solange wir das haben müssen, äh muss es sowas geben. Und es gibt eben Bereiche, wo äh das.
Ja.
Sagen wir mal eine Tätigkeit, die mich so bekannt ist, wie die Tätigkeit eines normalen Kriminalbeamten, der jetzt ein äh Delikt aufklärt oder versucht, eine Straftat zu verhindern
wo das eben nicht ganz so offen sein kann in der Kontrolle, muss genauso also muss es völlig durchsichtig sein, aber während er das macht
muss da nicht jeder gleich das alles auch wissen können.
Aber sind denn die Geheimdienste, in der zumindest in Deutschland, in dem Zustand, in dem sich derzeit befinden so unterm Strich eher eine Hilfe oder äh eher ein Problem.
Also es gibt diese berühmten Äußerungen von vielen Bundeskanzler, ich glaube zwei oder drei sagen
Sie haben das nie gelesen, was die berichtet haben. Und äh die regelmäßige Lektüre damals war die sehr hoch im Kurs der neuen Züricher Zeitung äh
war informativer als das, was sie da bekommen haben
ich war nun noch nie Bundeskanzler und weiß das nicht aus eigenem Erleben, aber das ist natürlich dazu. Dies ist ja ein riesiges Eigenleben und auch ein in sich Apparat
äh der, wenn man äh auch um Verfassungsschutzbericht liest heutzutage, er ist nicht sehr informativ, aber man merkt auch, mit was sie sich alles beschäftigen. Also wenn die eine ganze
Teilung haben, die sich dann mit der VVN oder äh mit äh den äh
alten Kollegen äh äh da einen ernsthaft als Gefahr für die Demokratie beschäftigen. Da fragt man sich immer
müssen wir dafür Geld ausgeben.
Aber
Die Geheimdienststrukturen sind ja auch schon sehr verwoben mit der Politik, was sich auch daran festmachen lässt, dass ja durchaus einige äh ehemalige Geheimdienstchefs dann auch äh recht
direkte Wechsel in die aktive Politik gemacht haben. Klaus Kinkel ist so ein Beispiel, es gibt weitere ähm ist das so klug.
Ich glaube, bei Kinkel war das. Das ist übrigens eine Tradition, äh die aus anderen Ländern kommt, USA und England, wo das sehr viel mehr ist und da
gibt's offenbar überhaupt kein Problem, ehemaligen Geheimdienstchef zu um Minister zu machen und umgekehrt äh äh ja.
Sehen sie das auch gut.
Da ist der Präsident, äh also das ist sicher richtig. Nein, äh ich will überhaupt nicht das, äh wie diese Apparate jetzt sind. Ähm mit was sie sich beschäftigen, wofür die sind,
Ich blicke da auch nur durch ein in die kleines Fenster rein, ne, muss man ja sehen
Alles andere wäre eine absolute Illusion, aber ich glaube, ähm durch äh solche Tätigkeiten, die von außen angeregt worden sind, haben wir da immer wieder schon sehr viel
auch Veränderungen erreicht, wenn man mal, ich kenne auch äh auch den Verfassungsschutz beispielsweise auch aus einem Untersuchungsausschuss
Mitte der achtziger Jahre von fünfundachtzig bis siebenundachtzig war ich auch schon mal im Untersuchungsausschuss dazu. Da haben die noch völlig anders funktioniert. Da ist zum Beispiel damals von uns auch festgestellt worden, dass die im Wahlkampf.
Dreiundachtzig. Da sind die Grünen zum ersten Mal zur Wahl angetreten. Da haben die äh.
Von der CDU die Bitte bekommen, doch mal über diese neue Bewegung da. Äh insbesondere ihre Kandidaten, insbesondere da gibt's so einen Kandidaten, der ist Chili
doch mal Informationen zu bekommen auch für den Wahlkampf
und heute glaube ich schwer denkbar, dass sie sich das trauen äh und dann wurde ein Dossier erstellt und an den bestimmten Abgeordneten
weitergegeben, nachdem sich der Beanstich sogar geweigert hatte, hat gesagt, das ist nicht unsere Aufgabe.
Aber überwacht nicht der gleich oder sammelt nicht der gleiche Dienst heute über die Linksparteimaterial?
Richtig. Richtig. Das ist muss man auch denunzieren, das habe ich und haben die Grünen auch immer gesagt, völlig unmöglich und.
Ist jetzt eingeschränkt worden und so, aber ist natürlich also vor allen Dingen nicht nur, wenn's jetzt ähm,
um die Partei geht, sondern vor allen Dingen um Abgeordneten. Es kann doch nicht wahr sein, dass also gewählte Abgeordnete äh äh der Bevölkerung, es sei denn, es gibt eine Straftat oder irgend sowas, äh sich äh
kontrollieren lassen müssen von einem staatlichen Geheimdienst, ne? Also völlig für mich äh völlig unbegreiflich.
Jetzt interessiert's mich. So, jetzt sind sie in dem parlamentarischen Kontrollgremium. Sie haben selber mehrfach äh die Erfahrung gemacht, eben,
Objekt des Interesses für solche Geheimdienste zu sein. Als äh äh Mitglied des sozialistischen Anwaltskollektivs, als äh als Anwalt der ähm der RAF ähm.
Jetzt grade nennen sie das Beispiel als äh dass die grüne Partei auch im Fadenkreuz stand, dieser Geheimdienstinteresses. Und irgendwann am am Ende dieser
oder am Ende ja doch jetzt am Ende dieser Laufbahn sitzt verbringen sie über ein Jahrzehnt mit der, mit der Geheimdienstkontrolle. Fordern
Gleichzeitig mehr Transparenz für diese Geheimdienste, aber das einzige, was wir an Transparenz für diese Geheimdienste im Moment haben, ist ja genau dieses Gremium, in dem sie sitzen. Und da sagen sie, ihre Informationen bekommen.
Mehr. Es gibt es gibt noch die Kommission, die wird ja von uns gewählt
muss jeden einzelnen der deutschen Dienste genehmigen. Die kriegen die Akte und müssen sagen, okay, also jetzt nicht so Massenüberwachung, sondern äh.
Der Herr Müller, Meier Schulze, äh der gegen dientlich das und das vor. Wir wollen jetzt, wir, der Bundesnachrichtendienst oder das Bundesamt für Verfassungsschutz, wollen äh dessen.
Handynummern oder weiß ich was kontrollieren. Ähm abhören, das muss genehmigt werden. Und deshalb haben sie ähm.
Auch äh die Konsequenz, das sind das, das genehmigt werden muss, ist dass das jedenfalls das offizielle Abhören
äh der von der Bundes, das gilt leider nur für Bundesbürgern, das soll natürlich nicht vorstellen muss für deutsche Staatsbürger, dass wenn äh dass wir die Zahl
der Abhörmaßnahmen äh gegen äh die von Geheimdiensten auskommen irgendwie bei.
Dreistellig, weiß ich jetzt nicht, dreihundert oder so was ist. Während die die Polizei abhören, bei fünfzigtausend oder so was ist im Jahr. Das ist äh
Also da sieht man, auch da kommen Fehler vor, wir haben das auch schon mit Fehlern beschäftigt, wo da Leute abgehört, die eigentlich gar nicht hätten abgehört werden dürfen, aber da hat man wenigstens so einigermaßen das gute Gefühl, da wird genau draufgeguckt.
Das ist ein Gremium von zum Teil ehemaligen Abgeordneten, die wir wählen wiederum als unabhängige äh Kommission.
Und wie stelle ich mir das parlamentarische Kontrollgremium vor?
Da sitzt man in einem abhörsicheren Raum. Das ist ja kein Geheimnis.
Paul-Löbe-Haus oder äh.
Ja, das war früher immer ganz geheim, wo das eigentlich ist, dürfte nicht gesagt werden. Also jedenfalls in einem fensterlosen Raum,
Übrigens äh zu Anfang, als der Bundestag nach Berlin kam, da war das hier in einem Gebäude, direkt gegenüber der Englischen Botschaft.
War nur eine Straße.
Somit dann auch das Rad oben auf dem Dach erklärt wäre.
Äh so und das ist jetzt in einem ganz geheimen äh Raum und da gehen angeblich die Handys nicht und äh das ist abhörsicher. Und da trifft man sich einmal im Monat in der Regel.
Manchmal häufiger, also wenn jetzt NSA-Skandal kommt, da war das dann alle paar Wochen.
Ähm und dann wird berichtet, die Bundesregierung ist verpflichtet, besondere Vorkommnisse zu berichten, aber das, was sie als besondere Vorkommnisse
berichtet, das war bisher, ich kann mich jedenfalls nicht erinnern, dass das mal einer der Skandale war, die dann nachher öffentlich wurden, sondern die haben wir dann immer
aus dem Spiegel gelesen vor zwei Jahren
äh war der Verfassungsschutz in Guantanamo und hat Herrn befragt oder so und dann sagen wir, was lesen wir denn hier? Warum ist uns das denn nicht berichtet worden?
Und was und was ist auf so eine Frage? Was ist da die Antwort?
Ja, klar, wir kriegen die Akten und äh irgendeiner gibt dann da einen Bericht und dann können wir da welche hören und dann reicht das nicht und dann machen wir eine Sondersitzung und so.
Wie kommt man sich also über Jahrzehnte in so ein Ding reinzugehen, wo man weiß, da vorne da erzählt jetzt einer irgendwie, der liest jetzt irgendwie den Bericht von der letzten Klassenfahrt vor, um irgendwie was erzählt zu haben.
Ein bisschen konkreter ist es schon und äh natürlich fragen wir jetzt auch, also sagen wir mal, das Ausland spielt ja auch eine große Rolle. Der Bundesnachrichtendienst, der,
mit Abstand größte Geheimdienst äh der hat glaube ich siebentausend Mitarbeiter, die jetzt hier nach Berlin kommen.
Ein opulentes Gebäude.
Ja, genau. Äh die äh berichten natürlich auch über alle möglichen Aktivitäten, die jetzt nicht gleich jeweils skandalträchtig sind.
Und da da kriegen sie also schon so einen zumindest die Großwetterlage mit, wo sich dieser.
Können wir Fragen stellen, da kann jeder Abgeordnete, ich kann fünf Tagesordnungsthemen für die nächste Sitzung beantragen.
Das heißt, die die Kontrolle kann eigentlich nur so gut sein wie die Fragen, die man an der Stelle äh fragen kann. Deswegen ist es.
Ja und natürlich auch der Mitarbeiter, das muss man sowieso wissen. Abgeordnete sind in der Regel nur so gut wie ihre Mitarbeiter.
Und ähm das heißt und der einer der großen Fehler ist, dass wir die Mitarbeiter nicht mit in das Gremium nehmen dürfen. Das heißt, wir bekommen die Sitzung eigentlich gar nicht mit.
Das ist,
in allen anderen Ausschüssen anders, also im Auswärtigen Ausschuss sitzt dann der mit einem Rechtsausschuss, sitzen die Mitarbeiter hinten, hören, was die Bundesregierung sagt, machen dann Sprechzettel und so. Geht hier alles nur sehr eingeschränkt, weil die gar nicht dabei sein dürfen.
Wer könnte denn diese Riegel ändern?
Jedes Mal, das beantrage ich ungefähr alle Jahre oder
äh in jeder neuen Reform. Wir haben jetzt zu Beginn wieder der neuen Legislaturperiode, wieder eine Geschäftsordnung beschlossen
da müsste aber noch das Gesetz geändert werden, dass die Mitarbeiter, die wir neuerdings haben seit der letzten Legislaturperiode, dass die auch da mit rein dürfen.
Bisher nicht durchgesetzt, aber irgendwann wird das kommen,
Also wir es gibt auch da, wenn man jetzt die Geschichte der letzten zehn Jahre sieht, ähm immer mehr Möglichkeiten, Rechte, Informationsrechte, zum Beispiel auch das Recht, dass äh von dem der Ausschuss ja manchmal dann Gebrauch gemacht hat
dass ähm der Ausschuss ein Bericht beschließt und im innerheitlichen Themen, der dann öffentlich gemacht wird, also ein paar Sätze,
der Vorsitzende und ganz wichtig, die äh.
Also die äh Leute, die das anders sehen, wie häufig die Opposition, die dürfen dann auch, auch öffentlich,
ihre dazu sagen, ne, dürfen dann sagen, wenn das öffentlich jetzt gemacht wird
in dem äh bei der Bewertung äh stimme ich nicht zu, aus denen den Gründen, ich sehe das ganz anders, ne? Das ist auch schon mal ein Schritt hin zu mehr Öffentlichkeit. So haben wir eine ganze Reihe von Sachen, die wir da dürfen, auch in dem Verfassungsschutzbericht.
Der soll in Zukunft öffentlich vorgestellt werden, können Fragen gestellt werden. Also wir arbeiten dran.
Also ich habe mir eine lange Skala im Laufe der Jahre erarbeitet, auch von meinem Mitarbeiter. Äh an Forderungen, wie wir das ganz anders haben wollen. Wir wollen letztlich auch darauf hinaus, dass das ein Ausschuss wird wie jeder andere
also der in der Regel öffentlich tagt. Das ist zum Beispiel in Berlin so, also der Berliner.
Die tagen grundsätzlich öffentlich, manchmal geheim, hier ist das so, dass er nie öffentlich da
Wir wollen, äh, das habe ich auch immer wieder vorgeschlagen. Das soll jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gemacht werden, äh, dass man, wie das in den USA ist, dass man hin und wieder in öffentlichen Anhörungen, die Chefs der.
Geheimdienste befragen kann.
Aber in Berlin ist das ja im Prinzip auch schon eine Reaktion gewesen auf einen äh Skandal. Also da musste auch erstmal wieder was passieren, dass ich das äh ändert. Den haben wir jetzt so auf nationaler Ebene noch nicht äh stattfinden sehen.
Das muss also alle haben gesagt, alle Fraktionen, alle Parteien, Herr Oppermann hat noch im Wahlkampf seine neuen Forderungen dargestellt. Die vergessen das immer relativ schnell nach mal nach der.
Ja, da hat man auch so viel zu tun, also es ist.
Äh und wir haben jetzt auch eine neue Geschäftsordnung beschlossen, da sind auch ein paar Sachen drin, äh aber die ganz, ganz wesentlichen sind dem äh nicht drin. Dazu müssten dann vielleicht die Grünen doch mal fünfzig Prozent kriegen.
Und diese diese Forderungen haben sie jetzt über über zwölf Jahre eigentlich erarbeitet und vertreten und gesammelt und hat.
Alles realistische und alles keine Spinnereien, sagen wir mal so, ne.
Davon gehe ich aus, aber ähm jetzt.
Jetzt ist ja ihre Zeit eigentlich, ihr Moment ist ja jetzt da mit dieser äh politischen, mit diesem politischen Forderungen an die an die Öffentlichkeit zu treten.
Und das tun sie jetzt auch gerade und ähm jetzt gibt's eine große Spinnerei, die da einen äh Untersuchungsausschuss
beschäftigt gerade, die Spinnerei stammt auch von ihnen oder geht auf sie zurück, nämlich Edward Snowden anzuhören oder Edward Snowden äh.
Ähm hier zu schützen, ihm Asyl zu gewähren und ihn anzuhören bei der Aufarbeitung äh dieser des NSA-Skandales.
Also ich bin mit diesem NSA-Skandal, der hat mir den ganzen Sorgen für ein verdorben letztes Jahr. Äh Anfang Juni ging das ja los.
Erst dachte ich na, ist eine der üblichen Meldungen, dass da irgendwie wieder was so und dann nachher merkte man im Laufe des Juni merkte man, das ist sehr, sehr viel mehr
und dann habe ich ja überall auch gefordert, ähm wir müssen da jetzt mal wissen, was Sache ist
und dann hat die Bundesregierung einen Fragenkatalog an die britische Regierung und den Dienst und an die US-Dienst geschickt, der es bis heute nicht beantwortet, obwohl sie wiederkamen und sagt,
der wird jetzt ganz zeitnah bei äh drei, vier Wochen, sechs Wochen haben wir die Antwort, haben wir bis heute nicht
So und dann habe ich gesagt, wenn man da jetzt Näheres wissen will, äh da gibt's doch einen Mann, offensichtlich, kannte der ja auch nicht, äh der da sehr viel mehr weiß, äh der ist noch nicht aus der Welt, den kann man doch mal, kann man mal hingehen und sagen, wissen Sie noch was und sind Sie bereit, uns das zu erzählen?
Das habe ich irgendwie, alle dachten immer, der Schröder, die wäre irgend so eine Macke. Äh habe ich immer wieder gefordert, gesagt, Bundesregierung, Bundesanwaltschaft.
Abgeordneten sollen doch mal dahin gehen. Hat keiner gemacht und irgendwann Ende Juni haben wir dann hier gesagt, ähm,
Also wenn die das nicht machen, probiere ich das mal.
Dann waren sie einen Tag Außenminister Deutschlands, zumindest.
War ja erst im Oktober.
NN berichtete.
Es war erst im Oktober äh also wir haben uns dann bemüht, das hat dann geklappt und äh seit ich,
also schon vorher war ich der Meinung natürlich ist das ein klassischer Zeuge. In England würde man sagen Krozeuge, äh die man da braucht, äh der
und das aufklären kann. Das hat er ja dann bestätigt. Und seitdem setze ich mich erstens dafür ein, äh dass dieses
die Afrikaner nicht liefern, die können uns ja ihre Akten alle von der NSA zur Verfügung stellen. Tun sie ja nicht. Zeugen zur Verfügung, Herr Alexander, kann da mal herkommen und uns das alles erklären, warum wie sie sich hier immer ein deutsches Recht und Gesetz gehalten haben, wie er gesagt hat.
Das kann er uns ja mal erläutern, aber.
Aber nur auf deutschem Boden, also.
Ja, das kann er sagen, wo er will. Wir würden auch rüber fahren.
Sie meinten ja immer, dass sie sich auf deutschem Boden an das Gesetz gehalten haben, aber ich glaube, die NSA-Zentralen gelten ja gar nicht als deutscher Boden.
Dass dass ja, ob das hier in Deutschland bewahrt, da wahrscheinlich nicht, aber mindestens, sagen wir mal, das mit dem Handy der Kanzlerin hat ja hier stattgefunden und das ist eigentlich, kenne kein Gesetz, äh, nachdem das.
Zulässig ist. Also es muss noch gemacht werden.
Da will ich jetzt mal einen Exkurs anstrengen.
Neon, und jetzt, jetzt gehen wir weiter und jetzt haben wir, habe ich zu gesagt, der muss hierher und dann haben seit August fordere ich das ja, möglichst her und dann war ich da, habe gesagt, ja, der weiß und so,
und jetzt arbeiten wir dran und alle haben gesagt, da kommt gibt's doch keine Untersuchungsausschuss, die Amerikaner werden das schon verhindern. Jetzt gibt's sie.
Und wir haben da lange gebohrt und jetzt ist unsere Aufgabe, ihn hierher zu kriegen. Und jetzt kommt er zu, seit ich da war, ähm.
Und ihn erlebt habe. Sie haben ihn ja inzwischen auch erlebt in den verschiedenen äh Video äh Geschichten, die er gemacht hat.
Bin ich so überzeugt, dass der Mann nicht nur recht hat und was Gutes getan hat, sondern.
Um die Welt sich wirklich verdient gemacht haben. Äh und deshalb wir auch ähm das habe ich ja dann im Bundestag auch geäußert, dankbar sein müssen, auch die Kanzlerin.
Dass er hier überhaupt dazu verholfen hat, dass sie weiß, dass sie abgehört worden ist und deshalb müssen wir ihm auch ein vernünftiges äh normales Leben ermöglichen.
Das sind zwei Gründe jetzt, warum er her muss. Und ich sehe die Schwierigkeiten. Äh ich habe auch ein gewisses Verständnis dafür, dass man sich mit dem großen Bruder,
nicht anlegen will, das tut keiner gerne.
Aber ich glaube, es müsste Mittel und Wege geben, wie man auch Verständnis etwa im US-Kongress oder auch in der US-Öffentlichkeit dafür.
Kann.
Ich habe nicht so den Eindruck, dass die so versöhnlich unterwegs sind.
Das äh ist zwar hinsichtlich Snowden persönlich.
Offenbar richtig, obwohl ich von Obama nicht mehr gehört habe, dass er sagt, das ist ein Verräter, sondern er äh hat ihn ja selbst in seiner Rede irgendwie als einen wichtigen,
äh
Impulsgeber, ja, genannt. Äh und wir dürfen ja nicht übersehen, dass im US-Kongress äh das äh Friedem-Act in Vorbereitung ist als Konsequenz-Stars.
Vorangetrieben von denen, die dieses Patriot-Act, also dieses äh harte Abhör äh Gesetz vorher äh also nach dem elften neunten äh.
Gebrachter.
Und auch andere äußern sich dadurch auch schon kritisch und wir dürfen nicht vergessen, dass führende US-Zeitungen wie Washington Post oder äh New York Times auch sich öffentlich dafür einsetzen, was sicher auch.
Ähm äh nicht so besonders akzeptiert für den weiten Kreisen der USA für eine Begnadigung.
Pulitzer-Preis jetzt dafür eingesackt haben, ja.
Ja genau, ja, ja. Äh also nie auch auch richtig eine Kampagne gemacht haben für äh.
Begnadigung von Snowden und so, also ich will damit sagen, auch da gibt's eine Diskussion, auch die USA sind da nicht monolithisch, einheitlich, sondern.
Auf die muss man hoffen und ich bin ja,
jetzt sind wir wieder ganz am Anfang, vielleicht zum Ende. Ich habe ja die Affären in den USA mitbekommen von Watergate,
äh bis und was da alles gegeben hat, die ihr alle irgendwie von Whistleblowern.
Die zunächst heftigst beschimpft wurden und ist vom Arzt bezichtigt worden sind, die heute hochgeehrte Journalisten und Persönlichkeiten in den USA sind. Er liebt also da habe ich durchaus die Hoffnung, dass da in einigen Jahren das anders gesehen wird
und vielleicht können wir dazu beitragen. Auch das Nobelpreiskomitee.
Mit welcher, mit welcher Reaktion der USA würden wir denn jetzt mal realistisch zu rechnen, wenn Deutschland
Das tut. Also wir haben ja sogar schon von Regierungsmitgliedern eben diese diese dieses Eingeständnis, dass man sich eigentlich gar nicht zutraut, diesen Mann hier Schutz zu bieten. Wovor?
Armutszeugnis ähm für unsere Sicherheitsdienste kann ich nur sagen, wenn man sagt, wir sind nicht in der Lage, eben hier davor zu schützen, obwohl man äh täglich,
oder mindestens jede Woche in Deutschland ähm Frohnzeugen, wichtige Zeugen für Strafprozesse, vor der Mafia.
Relativ sicher schützt. Vor anderen schrecklichen ausländischen Geheimdiensten und wovor man Angst hat
da sage ich, da halte ich fast alles für möglich äh und erinnere mich daran, dass noch neunzehnhundertneunzig nach der Wende.
Die USA hier einen ganz normalen wegen Straftaten gesuchten in Berlin gekidnappt und der US-Justiz zugeführt haben, ohne,
Affbefehl oder irgendwelche sich um solche äh Nebensächlichkeiten in Anführungsstrichen zu kümmern. Und äh ich bin ja, ich bin ja äh bei der.
Etwas in Unmenade gefallen bei einigen Medien, weil ich das immer schon so angedeutet, man
kann da ja nichts ausschließen. Was ich alles den Amerikaner zu äh also zuspreche, aber ich bin einfach durch einen Untersuchungsausschuss von drei Jahren gegangen und weiß zu, was die alles fähig sind.
Als die rot-grüne äh Koalition in Berlin mit der AL damals kam, ich glaube eine der ersten Entscheidungen war zu den Amerikanern zu gehen und sie doch zu,
dieses Recht äh dann nochmal darauf zu verzichten, was ihnen wohl noch zugestanden hat, hier irgendwie, wenn's Not tut, auch irgendjemand mal zu erschießen, weil quasi noch das alte Kriegsrecht
äh galt. Aber es gibt ja jetzt auch noch ein gewisses Alliierten äh Recht und soweit ich das verstanden habe. Hätte theoretisch auf dem Papier zumindest.
Politisch äh so durchsetzbar ist, steht auf dem anderen Blatt. Äh das amerikanische Militär schon, auch die Kraft äh hier oft
deutschem Boden zu sagen, naja, das ist hier eine unmittelbare äh Bedrohung äh der Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika, den schnappen wir uns jetzt mal.
Das stimmt so nicht. Also da äh ich nehme das natürlich auch wahr, dass da durch die Medien alles mögliche erzählt wird. Ähm.
Ich will nicht behaupten, dass sich alle Geheimvereinbarungen kenne. Wir werden in diesem Untersuchungsausschuss, den es jetzt gibt, äh uns alle vorlegen lassen, ob wir dann alle kriegen, weiß ich nicht, aber jedenfalls werden wir das fordern
die Vereinbarung, glaube ich, von dreiundfünfzig und.
Neunundfünfzig oder neunundsechzig, also die da immer durch die Gegend geistern, die sind tatsächlich aufgehoben worden im letzten Sommer, die gibt's nicht mehr
Aber auch diese Vereinbarungen sagen lediglich, dass die USA Anspruch auf Informationen haben, wenn ihre,
das hat immer mit den Stationierungskräften natürlich äh zu tun in Deutschland. Wenn ihre äh Kräfte in Deutschland, also die US-Bürger.
Gefährdet sind. Äh dann haben sie zur Abwehr dieser Gefahren, haben sie äh das Recht, Informations. Das heißt, es ist nach,
den Geheimvereinbarungen, die mir bekannt sind, nicht so, dass die nun einfach hier in Deutschland machen können. Faktisch ist es ganz anders.
Also ich weiß, dass im Zusammenhang etwa mit den Ermittlungen nach dem äh F neunten, also Hamburg und so, äh da haben wir uns immer wieder auch in dem früheren Untersuchungsausschuss darum gekümmert.
Ähm
was macht eigentlich die CIA? Da haben wir gar nicht so sehr an die NSA gedacht. Was macht denn eigentlich die CIA hier und wir wussten von Operationen, von denen in Neu-Ulm zum Beispiel
aber auch in anderen Gegenden in Deutschlands und da haben wir das nachgefragt. Was machen die eigentlich, ne? Auf welcher Rechtsgrundlage sind die hier tätig? Leute abhören, beobachten und so
Da wurde uns immer nur gesagt von den äh von unseren Diensten. Um die kümmern wir uns nicht. Das sind schließlich unsere Freunde und Freunde spioniert man nicht aus.
Ne? Und.
Also so äh ist da ist da die Lage. Natürlich machen die, wenn die schon mit solchen vielen Kräften hier sind, auch geheimdienstlich tätigen, wahrscheinlich vieles, was man nicht weiß, aber
von der Rechtslage ausgeht, dürfen sie das eigentlich nicht. Soweit ich diese Geheimvereinbarung kenne.
Also kurz gesagt, es äh es macht schon so den Eindruck, als äh könnte Deutschland Snowden hier einen sicheren Platz.
Wenn die wollen könntet.
Und warum wollen sie denn nicht?
Vor den Augenbrauen hochziehen in den USA sich fürchten.
Ja, aber ist nicht so, wenn der große Bruder die Braue lupft, das dann dann schon ganz schön Welle gemacht wird.
Es ist so, dass die, das kann ich nur immer wieder sagen, aus dem, was ich.
Erkenne oder erfahren habe, dass die sich nicht mal trauen, dem großen Bruder, so wie wir jetzt hier gegenüber sehen, in die Augen zu gucken und sagen.
Hey jetzt sag doch mal,
äh nur so ungefähr, wie viel Millionen Bundesbürger habt ihr nun da auf der Pfanne gehabt? Waren's jetzt fünf Millionen, waren's fünfundzwanzig Millionen? Waren's achtzig Millionen? Wir wollen doch nur so ein bisschen was wissen, weil wir in Deutschland immer gefragt werden
Selbst diese Frage, sondern da wird dann so geredet,
ein Problem in Deutschland, sie müssen das doch sehen und wenn sie uns nicht helfen bei der Bewältigung des Problems. So, ne, also es ist einfach ein, der ich sage immer, ein Devotes Verhältnis.
Ein bisschen jämmerlich, oder? Wenn das so ist.
Und woher kommt das? Also ich hätte erwartet, dass es ähm also
mal böse ausgedruckt, gedruckt, es war klar, dass dass sie sich da jetzt äh dass sie laut werden würden, ja, weil sie auch nicht ähm
wie gesagt, böse gesagt, nicht in einer Position sind, wo sie da jetzt irgendwie konkret was zu befürchten haben. Das wird ihnen ja auch von einigen kritischen Artikeln vorgeworfen, dass sie jetzt im äh in dem Untersuchungsausschuss ähm eine große Welle machen
und daraus politisches Kapital schlagen.
Ähm wie dem auch sei, also ich habe da im Freitag so einen äh äh Kommentar gelesen, der mich dann auch sehr gewundert hat. Ähm aber wie kommt es, dass.
Also wie viele Parlamentarier haben wir da im im Bundestag sitzen? Sechshundert dass das.
Dass keiner ähm diese Position laut vertritt. Niemand.
Das stimmt nicht. Also der Kollege von Notz, der vertritt das auch und dass wir die brauchen
auch wenn sie auf mit den neuen Vorsitzenden oder auch Vertretern der SPD oder auch der Union.
Die haben inzwischen auch nicht mehr das, dass sie sagen, der weiß ja nix und den brauchen wir gar nicht
sondern die sagen naja musst du vorher erstmal klären, gibt's überhaupt rechtliche Möglichkeiten und so. Aber das ist ein wichtiger Zeuge, das bestreiten wir auch gar nicht und so
Die Frage ist jetzt, wie stark ist der öffentliche Druck, dass die sich dem weiter entziehen können, äh den Zeugen hierher zu holen?
Also es ist so ruhig und äh bis Sonnenschein, die Debatte da doch nicht zu gehen, wenn jetzt grade der Herr Billinger da.
Nö. Na ja.
Äh also was war da überhaupt los?
Das weiß ich nicht. Der ist äh ich schätze den, ich habe im
NSU-Untersuchungsausschuss, glaube ich, mit ihm gut zusammengearbeitet und ach, die schätze ihn auch, weil er da auch Fragen gestellt hat, die durchaus kritisch äh waren und.
Die auch sachdienlich war, er ist ja kriminalbeamter, also konnte das auch ich verweise es nicht, verstehe es auch nicht,
Ich kann da auch nur immer wieder dazu sagen, nachdem, was ich gehört habe, ich bin ja da nicht dabei, ich gehöre dieser Unionsfraktion nicht an und auch der Bundesregierung nicht, dass es da äh.
Wichtige Debatten gegeben habe, um das mal neutral auszudrücken oder dass da auch äh in gewisser Weise Druck ausgeübt worden ist, jedenfalls eine Erwartungshaltung macht. Und das mindestens äh
dass vor der Reise der Kanzlerin, die ja jetzt offenbar jetzt nächste Woche in die USA fliegt, ähm.
Ungern hätte einen Beschluss, dass äh es eine ordentlich auftritt.
Weil das Ticket jetzt schon gebucht ist, das wäre schade. Wäre schade um die Reise.
Nee, das äh also ob sich das ändert und ob man da irgendwas findet, das,
sagt nur einmal, das hängt von den äh von den äh Verhältnis zu den USA ab und ich bin immer noch davon überzeugt, ich bemühe mich ja auch mit den US-Abgeordneten in Kontakt zu kommen.
Also als der Herr Senator Widen hier war, äh.
Habe ich versucht, ihn oder habe mal ihn angesprochen. Der war aber daran, der wollte nur hierher kommen, um gut Wetter zu machen. Äh der war jetzt nicht so im Thema.
Aber ich glaube, wenn ich mit denen mal ernst alleine reden könnte, dann würden die das zum Teil auch anders sehen.
Na, was hältst du davon ab, gleich das nächste Flugzeug zu besteigen?
Das die nicht jedem empfangen, auch nicht im Deutschen Bundestagsabgeordneten. Das muss man ja vorbereiten und die müssen ja sagen und die haben ja auch viele Termine. Und ob die sich jetzt darum reißen mit mir dann, weiß ich nicht. So wichtig bin ich auch nicht.
Schon lieber nach Russland.
Wird mich noch eine Sache interessieren. Äh abschließende Frage. Ähm sie sind gerade auf das Kanzlerinnen zu sprechen gekommen. Ähm.
Was für mich persönlich war das der äh und für viele andere Weise dieses äh ja sie hören alle Deutschen ab.
Auch die Bundeskanzlerin, ja, wie auch die Bundeskanzlerin. Also das Kanzlerin-Handy war ja nicht nur in Deutschland, sondern auch international, so,
das ganz große Ding, wo man was wirklich dann diesen diesen Skandal dann wirklich auch mal auf auf Regierungsebene dann den Schwung gegeben hat, ne? Ähm.
Für mich ist das nach wie vor schwer.
Rationalen nachvollziehbar, denn äh wenn ich eins von einem Geheimdienst erwarten würde, dann ist es, dass er die äh Regierungsmitglieder der jeweiligen Staaten ähm.
Genau unter die Lupe nimmt. Alles andere würde ich erstmal nicht erwarten. Ja, also politisch relevante Akteure
erwarte ich oder rechne ich damit, dass zum Beispiel der Bundesnachrichtendienst diese,
im Ausland beobachtet. Und ich bin, gehe auch davon aus, dass er das bei äh zum Beispiel in Frankreich macht, dass man sich darüber Gedanken macht,
Erstens, wer sind da im Moment die äh die Leute, die da das Sagen haben und was sind Ausrichtsreiche Kandidaten, die da in Zukunft was zu sagen haben und wie ist deren Verhältnis zu meinen,
zu meinen politischen Bestrebungen. Find ich.
Nicht gut, nicht richtig, wie auch immer, aber finde ich absolut offensichtlich.
Jetzt ist das mit dem Kanzlerinnen-Handy, aber an der Sache so eskaliert. Wir erklären sie sich das.
Ja, weil das gar nicht geht, wie die Kanzlerin gesagt hat. Das geht gar nicht. Das andere vielleicht, ne.
Also in einem Punkt haben sie Recht. Äh das ist äh natürlich äh ein wichtiger Punkt, dass auch Kanzlerin abgehöre, aber viel wichtiger ist, dass es wahrscheinlich,
Millionen oder zweistellige Millionen äh von Deutschen gibt.
Äh ähm Kommunikation von deutschen Bürgern, sei es in USA abgefangen, in den äh Glasfaserkabeln oder wo auch immer. Äh das ist eigentlich äh der Hauptskandal, sehe ich auch so.
Aber wahrscheinlich weggesackt, so Ende August äh als das nicht mehr so Thema, wenn das Kanzlerhandy nicht dazugekommen. Das ist dazu gekommen, weil.
Erstens die Uhrargumentation, die auch von Herrn Alexander bis zu Herrn Obama immer wieder gebracht worden ist. Wir machen das ja alles nur um die Welt und und die USA,
und übrigens auch die Deutschen vor dem internationalen Terrorismus zu schützen.
Diese Argumentation war nicht mehr so ganz ziehend, äh weil die häufigen Anrufe von Terroristen bei der Kanzlerin unwahrscheinlich sind.
Grenzen, ja.
Und äh deshalb, dass hier dieses ganze Gebäude fielen sich zusammen. Es fiel auch an sich zusammen, dass der Alexander immer gesagt hat, wir halten uns in Deutschland selbstverständlich an Gesetz und Recht. Das hat ja wirklich immer wieder auch öffentlich betont,
So, dazu ist er übrigens auch verpflichtet, nach allen also ist die NSA auch verpflichtet, nach allem, wenn sie hier in Deutschland tätig werden will. Es gibt
in diesen Vereinbarungen äh gibt's immer auch äh natürlich deutsches Recht und Gesetz muss beachtet werden
So, das waren sicherlich die zwei Punkte. Und dann war das auch, was wo das viel plastischer war, als wenn man sagt, alle sind jetzt werden abgewöhnt,
du und du wahrscheinlich ähm vielleicht wäre das, wo das hier so konkret war und wo es vor allen Dingen offenbar in dem Aufgeregten
Das wollen wir ja noch im Untersuchungsausschuss von der Kanzlerin hören, in dem aufgeregten Telefonat,
was sie dann mit Obama geführt hat. Er ja offenbar das irgendwie eingeräumt hat. Zwar nicht direkt, aber indirekt, dem wir sage ich, ja soll nicht wieder vorkommen so ungefähr. In Zukunft sind sie sicher
dafür werde ich sorgen, ihr werdet meine Amtszeiten also da sind viele solche zusammengekommen Gründe.
Weshalb das so äh herausragende Bedeutung hatte,
Wichtiger ist natürlich, dass äh die Gesamtbevölkerung das betrifft. Und jetzt, das machen alle und alle Regierungen. Da bin ich nicht so sicher, also ich glaube erstmal nicht, dass sich der deutsche Bundesnachrichtendienst leisten könnte.
Herrn Obama abzuhören oder dem britischen Premierminister und die Queen.
Ich glaube, das müsste wahrscheinlich ganz oben genehmigt werden und ich glaube, also jetzt vom Kanzleramt oder so, äh das machen die nicht, weil wenn sie dabei erwischt werden, ist das doch.
Noch anders als wenn's in Deutschland. Also raus, natürlich machen die auch die irgendwelche,
Informationsbilder, über neue Politiker, alte Politiker und geben die der Regierung, aber ist ja noch ein Unterschied, ob man die nach Zeitungslektüre macht oder nach äh allgemeinen offenen Gesprächen oder ob man
geheime äh oder vertrauliche, intime und weiß ich, was Gespräche am Handy abhört.
Also das ist ja der riesige Unterschied und gegenüber dass man das auch versucht äh bei irgendwelchen Potentaten in Nord und Korea oder anderen näher liegenden Ländern, das davon gehe ich auch aus, versucht, ob's klappt, weiß ich nicht.
Und.
Genau äh aber es ist noch ein Unterschied, wenn man das bei äh jetzt eine befreundete Regierung, woher Obama glaube ich eine Woche vorher oder zwei Wochen vorher gesagt hat, was regt ihr euch so auf? Wenn ich wissen will, was die Kanzlerin.
Denkt, dann rufe ich sie doch an.
Und jetzt war's auf einmal, wenn ich wissen will, was sie denkt, dann höre ich sie doch ab.
Noch dazu bei einer Regierung, die, wie man jetzt sieht, ja, wirklich handzahm ist. Also, vor der Regierung war ja nun wirklich.
Nee, das äh also das muss das muss man sich dabei ähm natürlich immer sehen und insofern sagen wir mal für die äh gesamtdeutsche Bevölkerung und.
Bemühen, das mindestens zu beenden.
Wenn ich auch irgendwie mit Sanktionen zu versehen, was da passiert ist. Das läuft ja im Augenblick, während wir hier sitzen, wahrscheinlich ja weiter.
Oder mit Sicherheit weiter die sind natürlich dadurch erhöht worden, dass das so eine Bedeutung hat und dass das auch sagen wir mal weltweit diskutiert worden ist und und so.
Wenn man über den NSA-Skandal äh diskutiert, kriegt man immer schnell zu hören, das würde ja dann auch keinen interessieren. Die Bevölkerung nicht interessieren, ist das so, mit ihrem Zugang zur Bevölkerung äh auch äh so festzustellen.
Nee, ich glaube, es haben, das haben auch schon die Regierungsparteien begriffen. Die SPD schon im Wahlkampf, CDU hat das ja etwas größere Schwierigkeiten, das zu begreifen.
Aber ich nehme auch an, äh auch die merken, dass das führt nicht jetzt zur Revolution und zur Massendemonstration, ich sage mal, leider,
es wäre natürlich nett, wenn die hier jetzt sich eine halbe Million vorm Kanzleramt versammeln würden. Äh aber die wissen, dass das äh.
Schon in der Bevölkerung wahrgenommen wird und wenn's dann Umfragen gibt, dass sechzig Prozent der Bevölkerungsnoten als Helden sehen, dann hat das, glaube ich, auch eine gewisse Eindruck bei der Kanzlerin oder auch bei der CDU.
Ich glaube, wir haben's, oder?
Ja, das wäre sehr gut. Ich glaube, ich bin viel zu lange jetzt.
Ja, es äh wir haben's.
Lange haben sie gar nicht genehmigt.
Ausgereizt. Ja äh insofern äh kann ich's mit äh Pofalla sagen und das Interview für beendet äh erklären. Und äh vielen Dank, Hans-Christian Ströbele. Genau.
Viel Spaß beim senden.
Alles klar, werden wir haben. Tschüss.
So, das war äh unser Gespräch, zwei Stunden hat's gedauert. Das war länger als ähm geplant, aber ungefähr so lange wie erhofft. Haben sozusagen den Zeitrahmen hier auch voll äh ausgenutzt.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass wir auch in Zukunft mit dem Logbuch Netzpolitik noch viele unterschiedliche Bereiche beleuchten. Und bin mal gespannt, wen wir uns zur Folge zweihundert uns zu Ehren einladen dürfen.
Müssen wir so lange erstmal wieder warten. Genau, mit äh weiteren Kurzmeldungen wollen wir uns äh wollen wir euch in dieser Sendung erstmal nicht äh weiter nerven, aber die hunderteins, die kommt ja äh bestimmt bald.
Vielen Dank.
Bis bald, tschüss.